this is Jocko podcast number 235 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening Cowie mayoral
one of my brother's awesome guy
incredible seal but at one point in time
I didn't know if he would keep his leg
the army doctors seemed neutral in their
assessment and my assessment was that
they actually didn't know and because
they didn't know my guess is they didn't
want to get his hopes up but at the same
time they didn't want to crush his
morale either and Cowie is the seal that
I wrote about in the opening of the book
that I caught of me leadership this is
the seal that told me he wanted to stay
he begged me to let him stay there in
Ramadi with us he did not want to go
home he wanted to stay with his platoon
he wanted to stay with the task unit he
wanted to stay with the soldiers and
Marines that we were fighting alongside
but the fact of the matter was that he
had to go he had to go he had to go to
better medical facilities with more
capabilities to see if he could keep his
leg and we're kind of standing there
talking to him kind of saying goodbye
because we know he has to go the brigade
commander walked in and we all quietly
came to attention
and I'd spent a little bit of time with
the brigade commander at this point i
briefed him on our capabilities been in
some planning meetings I'd seen him out
on the streets during a few operations
he was very well respected amongst his
troops the troops that we were working
with Army and Marines and his Brigade
Combat Team the 2nd Brigade Combat Team
of the 28th Infantry Division the iron
soldiers they had been fighting in
Ramadi for almost a year
then we from SEAL team 3 task unit
bruiser we had nothing but the highest
respect and admiration for all of them
they were professional they were
aggressive they were courageous and let
there be no doubt that the soldiers and
the Marines from the 2 to 8 saved the
lives of some of the seals and task unit
bruiser because they told us where we
should go and where we shouldn't go they
advised us on what to do and what not to
do
they rolled out and guided us on
operations they mentored and they
coached us and they did an outstanding
job taking the fight to the enemy and at
this point when I think how he got
wounded we'd been on the ground less
than a month and this was the first
significantly wounded seal in tasking a
bruiser and this brigade commander
Colonel John gronski was there too
paying a Purple Heart on cows chest
and I watched I watched the colonel
watched his attitude watched his
behavior he was solemn but at the same
time he was uplifting and what I could
tell is I could tell that he cared I
could sense that I think we all could
sense that and understand that at this
point he had done this hundreds of times
in the last year awarded purple hearts
to combat wounded soldiers and each time
I could tell that it mattered and each
time I could tell that it left a mark
and I knew that the colonel had also
sent many men on their final flights
home their angel flights Colonel gronski
had lost scores of men at this point
killed in action
and those obviously leave an even deeper
mark they leave a scar
and I watched as Colonel grant ski spoke
quietly to Cali I couldn't hear what he
said but Cowie
nodded and affirmed whatever had been
said and the colonel put the Purple
Heart Medal on cow his chest and they
shook hands again and the colonel left
and Cowie was soon on a helicopter
heading out a Ramadi and he would not be
our last casualty but he was our first
and he was my first significantly
wounded man while in a leadership
position and if you know anything about
me you know that I'm trying to learn
constantly and I learned from the
colonel that day the way he acted the
way he carried himself maintaining that
delicate balance because I could tell
that he was steadfast that these
tragedies would not discourage his
determination but I could also see that
he cared that he truly cared about Cowie
my brother my seal a man he'd never met
before I could also see that this was
part of our job as leaders we have to
bear this burden I would have to bear
this bird
and we would have to press on we would
have to do our duty in the face of
horrible wounds and tragic loss and I
knew that Colonel gronski had been there
for almost a year and I knew that I was
just getting started
and I knew I had to do my best to carry
the torch forward to bear that burden of
command to do my duty and to follow that
example
well
two strange thing because those memories
of war sometimes they feel like a long
time ago sometimes they feel like
yesterday but we don't forget them and I
won't forget what I learned and it's an
honor today to have the opportunity to
learn some more from that Carlin
although he is no longer a colonel he's
no longer in the army he retired as a
two-star general a major-general
who just wrote a book called the ride of
our lives and he is here with us today
general gronski thank you for coming on
the program Jocko thank you appreciate
being here yeah it's uh it was really
weird to see I was sitting in my car as
you pulled up to the parking lot today
and you know it may be obviously I
haven't seen you since the spring of
2006 and I remember meeting you for the
first time I don't know if you'll
remember meeting me for the first time
and I know that's you know when you as
they as the brigade commander you're
meeting people all the time people are
coming in and out when I met you for the
first time I went to your Tactical
Operations Center and right as I arrived
so we had been on the ground for just a
matter of days do you remember this at
all slightly how I'm gonna be outside
not in the detail you probably do note I
would be shocked if you remembered it I
walked in and as I walk into your
Tactical Operations Center the report
comes in that one of my SEAL snipers
there's actually uh btf Tony had just
killed an IE D in place er up on
firecracker and that kind of got
announced in the Tactical Operations
Center and you heard it and I knew who
you were because I had
gathered intel on you and read your
background and done research to figure
out who you were and what you know and
so I knew who exactly you were and and
just that that announcement following
that announcement you walked from the
talk into your office and then people
walked me into your office it was the
best introduction to human being could
ever want in a combat situation and you
looked at me and and you said that's one
of your guys that just killed us an ID
in Placer I said yes sir and you
immediately said I need your guys over
an Eastern Ramadi and I said we will go
wherever you want us to go wherever
there's bad guys and that was how the
deployment kicked off yeah Eastern
Ramadi was a pretty pretty bad place
yeah yeah and it was I think it felt
good I mean I could see the looks on the
people in the in attack Cooperation
Center the looks on their faces that we
just killed an ID in Placer and that was
right where in firecracker a few days
prior an ID had killed several Marines
and so often the enemy just you know in
Ramadi would just disappear they take
their shots they do their thing and then
they disappear that was really one of
the most frustrating things yeah you
didn't many times you just didn't have
an enemy to fire back at yeah before we
get into all that let's let's let's go
back because you know we all everyone
wants to know about you who you are and
I want to start off actually by reading
a little chunk of of your book to kind
of give a little background to everybody
and so the book is called the ride of
our lives it just came out I think in
February so I'm read this chunk right
here
my dad Paul Xavier gronski senior was
raised by his mother a Polish immigrant
my grandmother never learned to speak
English well she owned a small grocery
store selling primarily candy and
cigarettes my paternal grandfather of
also a Polish immigrant died in an
accident in the coal mines near Scranton
when my grandmother was five months
pregnant with my dad the son of a single
parent my father was forced to quit
school after the seventh grade so
could work and help support the family
my dad served overseas during World War
two in the US Army Air Corps dad opened
a garage in 1954 doing minor car repairs
and selling used tires soon he bought
cars to fix up and sell and so began his
venture into the used-car business his
family and his business were growing but
dad and my entire family faced a
devastating setback in 1956 when my
mother passed away when I was very young
that became a single parent with seven
seven children to raise and a business
to run it was a severe blow but dad
fought through it by outward measures my
father was unimpressive standing five
feet six inches tall
dad weighed about 135 pounds but my dad
was a grinder and he had the blood of an
entrepreneur through sheer hard work and
desire he raised his children while
building an enterprise that included a
garage used car sales a towing service a
boat sales and service business and a
bike shop known as Paul gronski
enterprises dad's business became a
landmark in northeastern Pennsylvania
Paul X gronski senior a man with only a
seventh grade education became a pillar
of the community and a leader in his
church that's the environment you grew
up in yeah do you remember your mom no
she died three days after I was born
oh and you you were number seven right
where'd your dad doing in the in the
Army Air Corps well he had a very basic
job he was a cook you know he worked in
restaurants in the 20s and 30s and he
became a cook and I think his favorite
war story was the time that he prepared
a meal for Dwight Eisenhower in the mess
hall that's that's a pretty memorable
story I'd be proud of that story right
and and what was it growing up I mean
obviously got you got no mom at home I
mean look I got four kids and I got a my
wife is a is
stay-at-home mom right and I could
barely control the chaos and mayhem
going on when when they were little that
must have been complete insanity yeah
you know it allowed us us kids to kind
of grow up with a lot of self-discipline
I was lucky though I had two older
sisters they became surrogate mothers to
me my sister Ruthie and my sister Ann
and then I had an aunt my father's
sister who was also a surrogate mother
so although I lost one mother I ended up
having three and I did feel a lot of
love in the family was Ruthie that much
or your two sisters how much older were
ya that I there both of a little over
ten years older than I am got it so you
know they were you know 10 11 12 years
old at the time
yeah and that's like 10 or 11 year olds
when they have responsibility put on
them they can pick it up and they can do
a lot exactly and you know you it's like
anything else you're put in that
situation and you just gotta dig deep
and you gotta figure it out and you got
to drive on and and that's and again
this was back in late fifties and I
guess it was a little bit more of a
austere life back then and people just
were able to stand up those challenges
like that how big was your house the
house I grew up in the best I could
recall my mother passed away they were
living in a single-family dwelling and
then again I just know this as I was
getting old enough to remember things we
were actually living in a house with my
grandmother got it so my grandmother was
in one room my aunt and uncle were
upstairs they kind of had the second
floor of the house and then everybody
else was spread out in bedrooms I mean I
remember my brother Jimmy sleeping with
my father in bed I mean they just slept
together that's how it was I remember
sleeping in in bed with two other
brothers I mean that just the way it was
back then yeah if you couldn't come up
with a good answer for how big your
house was I was gonna say alright how
many kids slept in your bed with you
I wasn't alone you're not the 757 kid
family with no mom and not having to
have shares of bed space exactly that's
that's the way it was and then don't go
into school and everything I mean but
what was what was what kind of school
did you go to yeah I went to a public
school when I was in first grade and
then I I'm a Catholic so I was put into
a Catholic school for second grade so I
could receive First Holy Communion but I
would have him to go through extra
classes like I would have if I was in
public school and then I went back to
public school again and in third grade
and continued my education in public
school your dad's an efficiency expert
yeah I guess he is and what uh what were
your interests in school well as I as I
got older my main interest was football
I just really loved playing football I
loved everything about it I wasn't that
great of an athlete I ended up starting
when I was a senior finally when I was a
senior I got I got the start on the
football team and I was an offensive
guard at a hundred and sixty five pounds
how big how big was your school was at a
big school is this would you go to high
school in Scranton in outside of
Scranton and it was a merged
School District Taylor and Moosic
Pennsylvania merge together named the
school as Riverside I think we graduated
around a hundred kids how big were the
games how many people showed up I mean
the stadium was packed and you know
northeastern Pennsylvania football is
king even today there's very little
soccer and a lot of football all those
soccer is getting bigger and you know
our school had I think three sports that
I mean they had bad football basketball
baseball and I think there was golf they
didn't even have track and field when I
went to school there in my senior year
we had intramural track and field but
you know never competing against other
schools now they finally do but no swim
team there weren't that many
opportunities for sports in the school
that that I graduated from at that time
what anything else you were interested
and did you have to work oh my god yeah
I mean you know it was kind of like a
family farm
you know I mean all my brothers and
sisters and I all worked in the garage
and I remember even when I was a young
kid in grade school I would be in the
garage sweeping floors I would be
studying tires you know at that time you
put stud and snow
studs and snow tires then when I was 16
I began driving the tow truck and that
that was pretty cool you know to go out
Co cars although in the winter man you
know winter in northeastern Pennsylvania
every winter we would get about you know
maybe three or four weeks where it was
like you know much below freezing so you
had to be out there towing cars jumping
cars you know with cables and and all
this you know changing flat tires in the
freezing snow it was pretty hard work
but so I guess I got used to using my
hands and and doing hard work at an
early age at what point did you start
viewing the military as an option well
you know my dad always really he was
very proud of the fact that he had an
opportunity to serve and he always
encouraged me to serve and when I
graduated from high school I went to a
college in the local area universities
grant and they had an ROTC program there
my dad wanted me to join the ROTC but
believe it or not even though I read a
lot of books about World War two and I
was very patriotic I was brought up that
way for some reason I just didn't want
to have anything to do with the ROTC and
so the first two years go by
no no ROTC even though my dad was
encouraged me to join and when I was a
sophomore I get this letter in the mail
from the ROTC program saying hey this
summer between your sophomore and junior
year you go to the space a camp at Fort
Knox and decide you know if you like the
army and if you do then you could sign a
contract and joined ROTC so I go to Fort
Knox Kentucky between my sophomore
junior year because really I just kind
of wanted to do something different you
know I guess I was tired of working in
the family business
so I forget how many weeks it was it
might have been six weeks or eight weeks
and man I just loved it I mean there's a
lot of camaraderie even there I mean
the drill sergeants I still remember my
drill sergeants named their sergeant
Ogden he was a short wiry guy Vietnam
vet and you know profanity was all in I
mean you know the Jody calls you could
they could sing whatever they put out
there we sang and it was pretty profane
and I just loved it
I just loved that the physical part of
it I love you know I'm being on the
rifle range
you know the tactical part of it so I
was all in you know when I left Fort
Knox Kentucky I signed the ROTC contract
and you know I was just so thrilled to
be part of part of that yeah so so then
you finished college and so what gears
it did yeah I I graduated from high
school in 74 graduated from college in
78 and then I went on active duty but
the thing is a lot of people don't know
this and I don't admit it to a lot of
people but it's kind of a interesting
story I was commissioned as well you
know you're about to admit this to about
time you Pete I know that you know I you
know I I'm still proud of my service but
I was a Medical Service Corps officer
mmm and the reason I was a Medical
Service Corps officer is the eye sight
in my left eye is right now it's about
2,600 at that time it was 2409
correctable I had a lazy eye when I was
a kid it was never corrected and once
you go so long with that there's no way
to correct that eyesight so because my
eyesight and my left eye was so poor I
couldn't become an infantryman like I
wanted to because most of my buddies
were going infantry or armored Field
Artillery combat arms I was in the
commandos at the University of Scranton
which kind of was really it was kind of
a ranger oriented group proud heritage
at the University of Scranton commandos
yeah what does a medical service officer
do you're an administrative officer so
at Fort Benning Georgia where I was
first assigned I commanded a medical
platoon and an armor in an armored
battalion so I you know I I wasn't a
doctor
anything like that but I was kind of
like the administrative officer who
would lead the medics you know provide
them the leadership that that they
needed and there's usually a physician's
assistant assigned your platoon as well
but that's where a Medical Service
Officer essentially does they could be a
platoon leader in an ambulance platoon
you know as a lieutenant or platoon
leader in a medical platoon supporting
an infantry battalion or armor to town
that's where a medical serve Service
Corps officer does so I did that for
four years and then you know I was
signed up Fort Benning then I went up to
Fort Lewis Washington and after four
years I left active duty mainly because
you know as a Medical Service Corps
officer to be quite honest with you it
was just something that didn't really
interest me that much and I figured okay
I did in my four years now I'm gonna get
out and then I had a decision to make
whether to stay in Tacoma Washington and
make a life for myself there moved back
to northeastern Pennsylvania what we
ended up doing was moving back to
northeastern Pennsylvania hey I got a I
got a pick up a book here for a second
to read through that kind of
decision-making process because well
I'll just go to the book you say here
after serving at Fort Lewis for about
two years I left active duty in the Army
in the fall of 1982 we stated Tacoma
Washington where I worked as an
alcoholism counselor and birdie worked
at that's your wife yeah worked as a
nurse we enjoyed living in the northwest
but we decided to move to music for a
variety of reasons first my dad was
getting older I want to spend time with
him I also wanted to raise my family
near my brothers sisters and friends
back in Pennsylvania and then you say at
the humble kitchen table my plans are
hatched and life important life
decisions are made homes are mortgaged
insurance policies or purchase and
weddings are planned the kitchen table
is remarkable in the winter of 1982-83
it was at our kitchen table where two
important decisions were made the first
decision was to leave Tacoma Washington
the Great Northwest and relocate to my
hometown of Moosic Pennsylvania the
second decision was a bit more
adventurous we decided to make the trip
by
bicycle the trip would be self supported
meaning we would carry our belongings on
our bicycles in packs known as panniers
am I saying that right yes known as
panttiere is we would keep these
belongings sparse to save weight only
one spoon each no forks a small pot to
cook in oh and only one bowl the pot
would serve as the other bowl I drilled
holes into the handles of our
toothbrushes ounces mattered we would
carry our home with us a two-person the
backpacking tent had two sleeping bags
that could zip together our most
precious cargo would be our baby who at
the time of our decision was only about
nine months old there was nothing we
could do about controlling the weight of
this growing boy we would adjust
elsewhere so so you make this decision
too that you're gonna bike across the
country did you had you done any
long-distance biking before this uh the
farthest I went before that would be a
hundred miles you know I'm gonna ride a
century did birdie go with you not not
on a ride of that duration no sir so you
kind of did a little maneuver to get her
to say yes to this well actually you
know my wife is from Austria I met her
when I was at Fort Benning she had spent
her most of her life in Austria until
she was in her early 20s and then I met
her when I was stationed of Fort Benning
she was staying with her aunt and uncle
in Columbus Georgia so we had only been
married a little less than three years
when we made this bicycle trip and being
that she was Austrian and then probably
understand the vastness of our country
she agreed to it she thought it was a
four-day trip not a three-month trip
right something like that and and really
this book is is a great kind of
recollection did you take notes during
this actually I kept the journal trip I
was gonna say because you've got some
really good details in there that bring
a lot of life to the story and I was
thinking myself there's no if you have a
memory like this then are the smartest
man that's ever lived
not my memory was the journal so you got
a bunch of great stories and really you
know the the the subtitle of the book is
lessons on life leadership and love and
you've got you tell the story and you
also work in a bunch of you know lessons
that you're learning along the way
you've got some stories in here that are
funny some of them are not so funny
you got this situation here you're and
I'm fat obviously I'm fast forwarded
through the book I'm skipping around but
at this point you had you had you had
talked to a farmer to see if you could
stay the night in his field which was
that what's the other weird thing about
this book in modern day in the year 2020
a lot of the things that you're doing in
this book might not be quite as
acceptable in modern times because
you're going to random people and say
can we stay in your yard can we stay in
the back of your house or whatever so
this is one of those situations you see
a farmer hey can we set up in your field
and and and the cool thing was and you
point this out a lot is people a lot of
people were hey yeah no problem you
don't come on in yeah you know we'll
make what we're making dinner you want
some hot dogs whatever so that was neat
but at this time you had set up in this
field a nice nice open field there's dry
grass everywhere tall dry grass and you
sleep the night get some good sleep you
wake up in the morning and here we're
going to the book ma the Morning Sun
brought the promise of another good day
of cycling the camp stove proved more
than cooperative for cooking oatmeal and
boiling water for hot coffee than it did
for preparing dinner the night before I
looked to the beginning of a great day
until I got clumsy just as our pot of
water reached a boil for our second cup
of coffee
my left foot kicked over the camp stove
this sun-drenched carefree morning
immediately turned chaotic white gas
began to run out of the toppled stove
the flame from the burner wasting no
time setting the dried grass ablaze the
wind howled from the west and fanned the
flames expanding the fire the flames
shot up to about eight feet in the air
and singed my eyebrows everything seemed
to move in slow motion
I had the sense that my life flashed
before my eyes would then we flung into
action Bertie righted the stove and I
put my firefighting skills to the test
my only chance was to create a firebreak
by stamping down the tall grass and
that's exactly what I did
it worked the fire fizzled out after
burning only a few square yards of the
field it was a frantic way to begin our
morning there was no fire or smoke
damage to the our tent sleeping bags
bicycles or to Stevens trailer that's
your now I think when you left he was 18
months old trip yeah Stephen did not
recognize the seriousness of the
situation we had a hard time getting him
to stop laughing at our antics so this
is the kind of this is the kind of
things that you talk about at this book
some of the lessons that you learn you
know on another section here you're just
talking about what what you're learning
it says throughout our cross-country
bike journey we fete we were faced with
countless decisions about which way to
go and which path to take what I learned
was that the path we decided upon was
always the right one it was not so much
about which path we chose but how we
chose to negotiate it it was all about
attitude so those are some of the
lessons that you learned on this trip
and the books the books really just kind
of filled with a bunch of you know funny
stories good stories lessons learned and
people definitely get this book so that
you can kind of kind of get that
background but eventually you you make
it across country you make it back to
music PA and there's all these things
that happen along the way you kind of
become a minor celebrity a minor
celebrity in the biking world for sure
maybe in the country but in music PA
it's like you're a town hero right oh
and maybe it's Stephen your son is the
ultimate town hero because he's the poor
kid that had to you know survive with
his crazy parents who biked across the
states with him in a trailer well I
think the real hero is my wife Betty I'm
indeed for her to make first of all like
you said agree to make the trip and then
actually make the trip never once why
never once said hey why don't we you
know pack it in and take a Greyhound bus
home I mean
I think she's the unsung hero for sure
what did you guys average you know 60
miles 70 miles 80 miles you know it all
depended we'd get up in the morning you
know talk about setting goals and
intermediate goals or ultimate goal was
northeastern Pennsylvania but we'd we'd
get up in the morning and look at a map
decide what town we wanted to make it to
that day based on terrain and other
factors and then we would set off for it
and usually was between 60 to 80 miles
so when you get back now
you're out of the army and you know
you're going into what what's the
business now morphed into well the
business was was very big they were
probably about I'd say about 40
employees working there at the time and
and again it was everything that you had
already mentioned you know garage used
used cars towing service very large boat
sales and service business and a bicycle
shop Paul how could you believe all that
stuff and it took up about a block in in
the town of Moon where are they using
boats oh there's there's plenty of
latest a bunch of lakes and in
Pennsylvania of fishing is very popular
there in waterskiing is as well so you
but you stay in the reserves no actually
well I did but when I get back to
Pennsylvania I didn't even know what
then I ended up joining the National
Guard but when I got there I had no no
plan to continue my military's okay so I
got that wrong you didn't stay in the
reserves you had actually left active
duty complete when I left active duty in
Washington I got in a reserve unit up
there and and then I moved back to
Pennsylvania with no plan to continue my
military service but somebody said to me
after about nine months being back they
said hey I want you go down to the
Armory in Scranton and talk to guys down
there about join in a National Guard I
had no idea what the National Guard was
surly explained the difference between
the reserves and the National Guard I
think everyone knows what active duty is
active duty is what you think of when
you think of the military yeah you're in
the military you're in the army you're
in the Navy you're in the airforce
you're in the Marine Corps you're in the
Coast Guard you're in one of those
that's what you do every day
that's the deal reserves and National
Guard explain those a little bit the
Army Reserve is you have a federal
mission I mean your main mission would
be to get deployed to conduct operations
overseas in the National Guard
you have that same federal mission but
then you also have a state mission so to
the National Guard generally during
peacetime or steady state is under the
command and control of the governor of
the state so that's the main difference
the reserves are not under the command
and control of the governor in the
National Guard the National Guard units
are and it's usually the National Guard
that gets called up when a hurricane
hits when there's bad weather when
something like that happens even some
kind of civil unrest
yes it's generally the National Guard
because they are controlled by the
states governors that's exactly right
the governor does not have any authority
to call up reserve units but they do
have authority to called National Guard
units although there's some talk about
changing that and I'm not sure where we
are with that with that right now with
the laws but generally in the National
Guard is under the command and control
the governor and so so that life is
similar to the reserves I assume and I
remember this since I was a little kid I
would hear on the news or I hear the
advertisement they'd say up one weekend
a month two weeks in the summer yes is
that similar that that was and it was it
was that way for the most part up until
9/11 and then after 9/11 everything
changed with the National Guard how
about the first Gulf War any impact on
the first Gulf War not a lot not a lot
primarily because it was it was a lot of
reserves were called up I don't know if
any National Guard units were called up
for the Gulf War there may have been if
there was there wasn't a lot probably
primarily logistical units in the guard
if they were called up at all and again
it was obviously very quick I mean you
know a hundred hours yeah you know you
know the build-up certainly was longer
but you know 100 hour war there so it
wasn't very long and so you're you're
doing your one weekend a month and
you're doing two weeks in the summertime
and other than that you're living your
life you know building the biz
this yes you're selling boats and
bicycles cars all that towing stuff yeah
and you're grazing your kids how many
kids well I
my second son Timothy was born in 1984
so yeah I had Steven and Timothy and
that's that's the two children that we
have and this whole time you're getting
advanced and ranked right and this is
something that we would always what's a
nice way of putting this so in the SEAL
Teams there's reserve seals and the but
there's not many of them there's more
now okay let me let me rephrase this
when I was younger in the SEAL Teams
there was not a lot of reserve seals no
one really even knew about it and most
guys just frankly stayed in the SEAL
Teams and if they got out they got out
they were done right you know they got
out and so there wasn't a lot of
reserves so guys that were in the
reserves would Manc rank really fat like
way faster than a normal seal at least
it seemed that way
uh-huh and at least we held that grudge
against them so if someone showed up for
their weekend drill and they were a
high-ranking guy you're a reservist do
you know what you're talking about but
that's what's happening while you're in
the reserves
you're the national guard even though
you're only working one weekend a month
you're still advancing in rank you are
but it's different a National Guard rank
is much slower okay much slower just the
way it is I I never knew it was that way
in the reserve seals that they made rank
quicker yeah and I don't know if it's
like that anymore and I don't even know
if it's just the way that I was raised
five hundred right by the guys that
would look at the reservists and say
that guy who's only made rank cuz he's
in the reserves otherwise he's too much
of an idiot you know it might have just
been some prejudice against the reserves
that was instilled in me by by the
active-duty guys yeah but but yeah I
guess my point is for people that don't
that don't understand the National Guard
reserves is that you're still advancing
in your career oh you are yeah and and
you know you have your civilian
responsibilities but you also have your
military responsibilities so all of the
things that go along with maintaining
military standards still exist even
though you're drilling you know in
theory one weekend a month in and two
week annual training at some other time
of year usually in the summer but you've
in terms of physical fitness standards
you've got to maintain those physical
fitness standards on your own because
you know you have US Army on your
uniform and that was very important one
thing I did want to back up on a little
bit though Chaco is is you know when I
came back when I did make that decision
to join the National Guard because the
guys there seemed like people I wanted
to work with and remember I was a
Medical Service Corps officer when I
left active duty I got branch transfer
to become an infantry officer when I
joined the National Guard and this was
about 1984-85 timeframe and really I
became an infantry infantry officer
without having to go through any
additional training it was essentially
at that time and I don't know if it
happened today or not but again we're
talking about 40 years ago almost you
know it was basically some paperwork
that was adjusted to branch qualify me
as an infantry officer and then I took
command of an infantry company yeah in
in West Pittston Pennsylvania and I
commanded that company for about four
years and just due to a lot of good
teammates there and good soldiers there
the company really performed very well
so well that we were given the honor to
go to the National Training Center at
Fort Irwin California as an opposing
force company opted for opted for
company which was a big deal for us I
mean that the guys were psyched yeah
back then I think this happened in 86 or
so memory serves me correctly that was a
big deal for us yeah and that's that's
actually an awesome thing so OPFOR just
to explain people that are civilians
opposing force that means you're going
to be the role players that are going to
be pretending to be the bad guys and I
my seals when I was the training
commander out on the
coasts I had a pack of guys and that's
what they did they they'd not only
taught but then they were opted for as
well and the thing that the thing that
is very important about it there's
multiple things that are very important
about it number one the seals that we
put through training or never going to
face a tougher enemy than the other
seals that were playing up for never
there would never be there's never gonna
be a tougher enemy ever and number two
when you're on opt for you learn how to
think like the bad guys you learn what
it looks like you learn how to set
things up and so then you can counter
those tactics so it's a it's a very
important it's a very important learning
process so for you guys and you probably
went out there for a pretty big chunk of
time yeah we were out there I think it
was uh at least three weeks you know a
normal annual training is two weeks but
we were out there for an extent extended
period of time did they send you to any
schools or anything when you became an
infantry officer me yeah
well that that's the the next story is
when I left command of that company
after about four years I I just knew I
had to do something to gain more
credibility and so I sought out and
thankfully I was able to go to the
infantry officer Advanced Course the
resident course at Fort Benning for six
months which was great and then I while
I was there I fought to get in the
Ranger School and so I started Ranger
School the day my class graduated the
infantry officer advanced Corps so I
didn't go to the graduation we call it
iOS a at that time infantry officer
Advanced Course so the day my class
graduated was my first day setting foot
and the Ranger school at Harmony Church
and it was just uh something I had
wanted to do for a very long time
because a lot of my classmates back at
the University of Scranton went went to
Ranger School just something I really
had my heart set on just like you wanted
to you know go through the SEAL training
and it was a very defining period in my
life to go through Ranger School how old
were you and you went through Ranger
School yeah I I started when I was 33
and had my birthday there so I graduated
when I was 34 years old so I was one of
the older
guys graduating from Ranger School
that's that's old for Ranger School
that's that's on out there there's been
older guys graduate you know oh yeah I
think there's I heard stories about a
sergeant major who graduated when he was
45 years old
I salute that guy wholehearted yeah yeah
but I'll tell you it was a it was an
ass-kicker for me you know and and uh
but I was you know I just didn't want to
quit and just kept with it and thank God
I made it through so were you a captain
at that point I was a captain yeah cuz I
was a captain when I left active duty
and and so you're still a captain you
were still alive was still a captain
captain for a long were you yeah look
this is what you were talking about the
reserves Thanks exactly exactly
so your cap suit but you go to Ranger
School you go to the infantry officers
course that so now you're starting to
feel like like an infantryman you know
like I've got like I've got the
requisite training that that is
necessary for one to perform their job
the way you should perform your job and
obviously it was your was your dad still
running the business yes you know and so
he took he was okay with you being gone
for yes ten months yes yes and that's
about how long I was gone it was about
did he did he did he ride you about it
was he stoked on it oh he was stoked on
it I'm very proud yeah because I could
also see a little bit of you go play
army I'll be back here working huh no no
he was very proud it wasn't that kind of
attitude at all and yeah that's yeah you
said he wasn't he in the Army Air Corps
yeah wait so what year did you graduate
from Ranger School 1991 so I went I went
to the Advanced Course the infantry
officer advanced course I started in
August of 1990 and we graduated in
February I think was February 2nd and
that's the day I started Ranger school
February 2nd 1991 so that's so the Gulf
War happened while you were at the
infantry course right what were you
thinking about that was it just kind of
no no I mean very interested obviously
and everything that was go
going on but you know didn't you know
didn't have to play a role in that
did that drive you crazy yeah yeah I
mean absolutely and you know when when
you're in the Army you want to do your
job that's what we trained for so yeah
absolutely it did the Gulf War goes over
really quick do you remember
so I remember so I was I graduated boot
camp I went to boot camp in September
September 13 1990 ok so the war kicked
off after that but I remember I'm
watching CNN with a bunch of other Navy
guys and the report CNN was saying
there's going to be 40,000 casualties in
the first 48 hours right I remember that
and I remember thinking oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna get mine because you know I was I
mean you might have thought you wanted
to go to war when you were 33 years old
I was 19 and I was you know completely
was was was hoping to go to war and yeah
so I remember watching that thinking oh
I'm definitely gonna get a chance
because if there's 40,000 casualties
that means this thing's gonna last a
while and that means I'll be able to go
oh yeah
which I know I know people I know it's
hard to understand that concept of
wanting to go to war but hey you're
young you're dumb and that's what you
want to do like you said you trained for
it that's what you want to do and and
the thing is Jocko you know your buddies
are going and and you feel like man you
know my buddies are going I want to be
there with them and I think there's a
lot a lot of that and you know and when
I say buddies I'm using that in a very
loose term but I mean my fellow you know
sailors are going my fellow soldiers are
going fellow Marines they're going so I
want to be a part of it you know I think
it's that type of attitude so that that
war like you said is over 100 hours and
now you're back to work you're back
Hawking bicycles right I mean you got
the experience you must have been a hell
of a Salesman and sell the vehicle we
had a pretty successful about for time
there yes
time goes by you're still getting
advanced in rank eventually you make
major where are you on September 11th on
September 11th I am a colonel who had
just successfully commanded a brigade
for over three years 55th brigade which
is a Pennsylvania National Guard Brigade
and in the sum I left command in the
summer of I'm trying to remember here
no I different I spent a year in
Lithuania in the year 2000 so I come
back from Lithuania in January and that
was that on national guard dude yes yeah
national guard duty I was spending a
year in Lithuania because Lithuania is a
state partner of the Pennsylvania
National Guard and I get getting into
that in a little bit but to answer your
question I get back from Lithuania in
January 2001 and then I take command of
55th Brigade in July of 2001 so I was
actually in command of 55th brigade at
the time got it and what happened is I
took 2,000 soldiers from the 55th
brigade over to Europe in 2002 to do a
force protection mission there at the
army bases in four different countries
in Europe Germany Italy Netherlands and
and Belgium while the active duty troops
are getting prepared to deploy deploy
either two to Afghanistan or as happened
to Iraq so I took two thousand soldiers
over to Europe
I said summer 2002 we spent a little
over six months over there doing force
bro for me that was an honor I mean I I
never thought I would have a chance to
serve overseas to command soldiers
overseas so to me that was a great honor
and and did our mission as well as we
could do it and and the soldiers perform
very well over there
and came back from that mission and then
after about a little over three years
almost four years I left command of the
55th brigade so that that mission to
Lithuania trip that was one year yeah
yeah what was that job okay that job is
and let me explain the state Partnership
Program real quick right after the fall
of the Soviet Union the US European
Command R which is a four-star generally
has the combat command you come they
call it as is the abbreviation he wanted
to develop an engagement strategy with
former Soviet republics or worse out
Pact countries to just create better
relations with these countries as they
were leaving the Soviet Union sphere of
influence and so he talked to the
director of the Army National Guard or
the chief of the National Guard about
getting National Guard States partnered
with some of these countries and so I
don't know how the decision was made but
Pennsylvania was partnered with
Lithuania and as part of that
partnership as Lithuania was trying to
learn how how does the United States
military operate because they wanted to
pattern themselves after us we had
various Colonels from the Pennsylvania
National Guard go over to Lithuania got
it spend anywhere from a year to three
years over there so in 2000 I was tapped
to go over there and it was just a
something I was really excited about
because again this is prior to 9/11 I
thought man I'm gonna get a chance to
serve as a colonel overseas I mean this
is great because who could have
predicted I know what I mean I couldn't
learn I couldn't predict 9/11 at that
point so I thought that was going to be
my only shot to serve serve overseas as
a commissioned officer so I was very
excited about it did you get to take
your wife on that note was unaccompanied
unaccompanied yeah yeah but my wife that
that is just how my wife bare he is that
when I call her an unsung hero she
really is I mean she supported me
through everything we've been married
we're gonna be married 40 years the
September so if she didn't leave me
after that
bicycle trip you know I guess I thought
Jojo she's never gonna leave but put an
end of the test early yeah and again I
come home one day and say hey Bertie you
know one of the generals from the
Pennsylvania National Guard wants me to
go over to Lithuania for a year how do
you feel about that she said John you do
whatever you think you need to do I mean
that's that was her whole attitude so
you did that mission then you come home
and then September 11th happens and now
you deploy again as a as as a brigade
commander with 2,000 soldiers over there
and in Europe and the thing I'm most
proud of is the fact that if we had
discipline disciplinary problems we
handled it you know very quickly our
soldiers performed well didn't embarrass
anybody did their job very
professionally as they were conducting
force Pro at these at these bases
because again after 9/11 you know yeah
you know what was gonna happen with
terrorist attacks at our armed
installations over there so very proud
of the way the soldiers performed we had
group I had three battalions tasks
organized 2,000 soldier Brigade and
leadership at all levels functioned very
well right down to the soldier level and
they perform well one quick story I had
I had a former Navy SEAL who I'm sorry
of I guess he was a Navy SEAL we caused
problems he really didn't know that this
guy leaves the seals he gets a job
working for this pharmaceutical company
because he had some type of degree that
he got when he left the seals he was
making $250,000 a year with his
pharmaceutical company Navy SEAL now
he's a staff sergeant in my brigade
working for peanuts whatever a staff
sergeant makes so he leaves a $250,000 a
year job to perform over there as a
staff sergeant I mean just stories like
that what Guardsmen happen all the time
where they they leave these very very
lucrative positions to get you know pay
as a as a specialist which is an e4 you
know I mean it's incredible the
sacrifice
these these great Americans make yeah
that's that's true service right there
yeah so you come home from that
deployment and now it's 2002 we got yeah
we yeah we got there in the summer of
2000 oh is 2003 so we got there in the
late summer of 2002 and we get back home
after the first of the year 2003 and at
this point what if one of your son's is
in the reserves or is in the National
Guard
my son Timothy was in the National Guard
okay
and so you're seeing September 11th
unfold yeah
at what point are you thinking that
though the call might come to deploy to
Iraq or Afghanistan for myself yeah just
yeah yeah for yourself well our second
Brigade got noticed that they were going
to be deploying over to to Iraq and I
think they got the notice they they
actually got mobilized in January 2005
so they got the notice about six months
prior to that so and we were you the
brigade commander yet or no no I was not
I I had left 55th brigade after
commanding there for three years
a little over three years and I was
selected to become a general officer so
I was actually at our state headquarters
in an O seven position waiting to get
promoted when I heard that 2nd Brigade
was going to be going over to Iraq now
Jack Allah this is the weird thing when
I heard 2nd Brigade was going to get
mobilized and go over to Iraq something
told me I was going to go with them and
I don't know what it was I just believed
I was going to go over there with that
brigade and and the way it happened is
when they actually got mobilized and
they we went that that Brigade went to
Camp Shelby for about five months to
train at Camp Shelby Mississippi and
this was January January 2005 I get a
call on a
Friday from the division commander of
the 28th Infantry Division that said hey
the current brigade commander went
through the readiness processing there
at Camp Shelby it was like the first or
second day on the ground there and there
was a medical issue no fault of his own
very honorable man who wanted to go with
this brigade but had a medical issue
that was going to prevent him from going
over and so he was going to go through
the SRP testing again on Sunday just to
make sure he couldn't go and so Sunday
comes he gets disqualified and so my
division commander called me back on
Sunday and said hey John he didn't make
it through could you be there on
Wednesday and so it's like absolutely
was the division commander a friend of
yours no I mean we had a professional
relationship I won't say he was a friend
did you had you told him that you were
ready to rock and roll
I actually told him a months prior to
that that hey if anything and I don't
even know what I was thinking but I said
if anything happens where you need me to
go with this brigade I just want you to
keep me in mind
and he and he did and I was thankful for
that just because it was an honor to be
able to go over there and do that that
job did they put your your general
selection on hold yeah I was basically
put on hold
I'll tell you the truth and I'm not
saying I mean honestly if I had a choice
and I truly meant this because I knew
there was a chance I might not get
promoted you know because I was taken on
this mission because just the way it is
right now but if I had to choose between
the two serving in combat with with
those soldiers and Marines or getting
promoted to general serving in combat
would be the thing and luckily you found
this out as soon as the workup kind of
started as soon as the training started
yeah you went down there on so you
missed two days right I mean yeah you
miss nothing exactly I mean I'm I was
down there yeah within the first five
six days of their training start up and
kind of an interesting story I want to
tell you the kind of links the the time
we had in Europe at the time of me going
to Camp Shelby to begin commanding the
brigade we first got to Europe in 2002 I
had a decision to make as a brigade
commander yeah 2000 soldiers spread
throughout four countries in Europe and
I made the decision that hey when you're
off duty you could drink alcohol you
know I wasn't going to tell these guys
you're over here in Europe and you're
not going to be able to go out and have
a beer and that's one thing I believe in
is not not setting a you know not not
setting out a standard or a rule that
you're probably not going to be able to
enforce anyway and plus it doesn't make
sense just because a guy puts on a
military uniform doesn't make them
stupid you know what I mean and so these
are adults so I said yeah you know you
could drink over there but I said I'm
just gonna let everybody know you get in
trouble you're gonna be disciplined we
had a guy who's there about two weeks
gets drunk gets in a fight with a German
civilian throws this German civilian off
a balcony the Germans civilian loses an
eye
so we court-martial this guy and he ends
up in the stockade and Manheim busted
him down from an e6 21 from a staff
sergeant to a private then I had another
decision to make do I discharge this guy
from from the army so I talked to the
battalion commander and I said hey what
do you think and the battalion commander
obviously knew this guy better than I
did and he said you know he is a good
soldier you know he needs alcoholism
counseling etc etc but he said I believe
he's worth retaining so I listen to what
this battalion commander said so I
retained them then on Christmas Day this
is about maybe four months later or
something I don't know four or five
months later Christmas Day and by the
way while I was over there with these
2000 soldiers I was on the road
constantly just going doing circulation
seeing how the soldiers are going
Christmas day I wake up and I say to my
driver I say we're driving up the
Mannheim today it's about an hour and a
half north
where my headquarters was so I want to
see the sky in the stockade it was
Christmas day something just told me to
go visit him so I go up guard brings him
out into the visitors area I was the
only visitor there that day and he was
just blown away when he saw me he goes
colonel you know it's Christmas Day
you're here to see me I said listen I
said you you screwed up you're paying
your dues you're still one of my
soldiers I said I wanted to come see how
you're doing let you know that we're
still thinking of you you're still one
of ours I asked him how the family was
doing all that I mean he felt like crap
being in that Detention Facility fast
forward
I didn't think another thing about it
left that was done it was my duty to do
that I did it and fast forward to the
first day on the ground at Camp Shelby
after I went down there to take command
of that Brigade walking through the
barracks area and there's four soldiers
standing outside of the barracks and one
of them comes sprinting over to me you
know stands there Detention salutes it's
a specialist in e4 same guy and he goes
you probably don't remember me because
but you came to see me in the stockade
on Christmas Day he goes I just wanted
to tell you how much I appreciate that
he goes I never forgot that and then he
yells over to the three other soldiers
that were standing outside of the
barracks with them because a lot of guys
didn't know who I was you know who's
this new guy coming to take command and
Brigade heels over those three soldiers
he said this is Colonel gronski were in
good hands with him and and I'm sure you
know coming from an e4 that meant a lot
if you know what I mean yeah and but it
just shows that you just try to do the
right thing for people you know and you
don't just discard somebody just because
they made a mistake and now this guy was
going to the most violent place on the
face of the earth to continue to serve
our country did you guys know you were
going to Ramadi we learned while we were
at Shelby we learned we're going to
Ramadi and then uh we kept thinking man
are they going to change their mind
because you know we were getting you
know we were getting all the classified
reports you know of what was going on
over there and we saw how violent
by the way 2nd Brigade 2nd Infantry
Division was over there at the time
that's who we did they're really from
place with and those soldiers and
Marines who worked for that brigade
commander Garry Patton who was a
outstanding American he ended up
retiring as a Major General very proud
of his leadership over there with that
with that unit but we saw how violent
was and we thought man they gonna send a
you know our brigade over there and they
did and I actually talked to a retired
three-star who was the M&C I commander
at the time after he retired and I said
sir I said you know I'm just I have to
ask you why did you send a National
Guard Brigade to this most violent place
on earth and he said well I was talking
to the first army commander and he said
you guys were ready and he goes then I
talked to my boss who was the M&F
commander and he said he asked me my
opinion he said sir we've been taking
risk everywhere else over here I think
we'll take some more risk and put 2nd
Brigade 20th Infantry Division in Ramadi
but those soldiers who were part of that
brigade and the Marines who were tasks
organized to us did a remarkable job
just because of leadership at every
level below me and just so proud of the
work those guys did in Ramadi how well
did the work up prepare you the training
cycle that you did and and you guys went
out to Fort Irwin as well right yeah we
did we just we spent a month out at Fort
Irwin as part of that train up you know
counterinsurgency doctrine wasn't even
published at that time coin doctrine
didn't exist until after we got back
home after 2006 that's when it was
published so we were given the best
training that the army was able to give
us being what they knew at that time but
certainly not as van't as advanced as it
as it became so the army did the best
they could do with the training they
gave us and the what did you guys have
for armor
I'll tell you when we got over there we
had what we called hillbilly armor it
was basically armor that was welded on
to Humvees it wasn't up-armored Humvees
and we had a fight to get the up-armored
Humvees we needed in Ramadi because with
that hillbilly armor there was a a
slight gap in the door I mean you could
actually see space in between when the
door closed and the rest of the vehicle
and you know how the ID threat was over
in Ramadi we had over a thousand IEDs
used against us while we were there and
without the right protection we were
just going to take even more casualties
than we did take and by the way the
brigade that was there before us took in
the 80s in and killed in action we took
82 killed in action and about 260 who
were wounded seriously enough who had to
be evacuated back to the United States
that doesn't count the ones who were
wounded who were able to stay there and
then the brigade after us who you worked
with for a lot of your time there took
about the same amount of casualty as we
took so you know every brigade that was
in Ramadi every army Brigade for you
know three consecutive brigades were all
taking into ATS in terms of ki a so you
needed the protection and we fought for
the protection and we finally got the
the up armored Humvees that we needed to
be able to better perform our mission
did you guys deploy all at once and
straight into Ramadi is that how it
happened or how did it or how I should I
say how did it happen I'll tell you my
brigade at Shelby I had over 35
different states contributing soldiers
to my brigade I mean that's amazing so
you know you want to train with you want
to go to war with the unit that you've
been training with but because at that
time in 2005 a lot of National Guard had
been used at that time they I had
soldiers from 35 different states
showing up at Camp Shelby so now we
could start training together as a
a team and another interesting thing
there was not a direct support feel
utterly battalion in the guard available
to deploy with us so we had to use a
general support fill Artillery Battalion
the difference the fire support element
a fire support element is where the
forward observers are usually in a
direct support Field Artillery Battalion
there's 135 fire supporters the guys who
call in the fire and a GS a general
support Artillery Battalion there's no
FSC because they use Ford observers from
the direct support artillery battalions
to call in the fire we had a cobble
together a hundred and thirty-five
soldier fire support element while we're
on the ground at Camp Shelby and that
took months to get everybody there in
groups of twos and groups of threes to
put this fire support element together
the reason I say this is this is just to
credit to these National Guard soldiers
who came together like they did and then
did their job superbly that's why I'm
telling that story it's it's not a knock
on anybody it's not a knock on the army
it's it's a credit to these soldiers who
were able to come together and then form
themselves as a team to do the hard work
that they had to do in the most violent
place on the face of the earth for a
year you know it's interesting I'm
thinking about a podcast that we are
actually a couple podcast that we just
did about the Boer War and the British
went down there yeah and what's
interesting is it was only a very small
part that I that I mentioned and the
reason I mentioned it on the podcast was
because the the ta which is the
territorial army which is the reserves
in in England there was a they gave
several examples but one specific
example where the guys that were
reservists so the guys that weren't
professional soldiers in many cases were
the first ones to say hey wait a second
the way we're doing this doesn't make
sense you know and they so they had I
would I guess they had their I there are
their minds or more old
and and they were they can adapt where
they weren't so rigid and I thought I
was I was thinking when you were saying
oh they made a decision to send the the
you know the the National Guard there if
I was the commander that may be
something that you wait and go look I
need someone that's gonna attack this
problem may be a little bit different so
that's a an interesting concept but also
just knowing and you know I mentioned
this at the beginning the effort that
your soldiers and Marines took to take
care of us when we showed up literally
saved our guys lives there was missions
I mean there's a specific mission that
Lafe babban who wrote these books with
me he was gonna go he was getting from a
Special Operations Group was gonna do an
operation and he was gonna take some of
his you know his seals and his Iraqi
soldiers they were gonna go and help
them and he brought it to you brought
the plan to one of you know one of your
majors out of Vermont I want to say you
know and I know exactly who that guy was
yeah I do too yeah and I mean he's just
and he looked at life and said if you go
down the street you're gonna get blown
up mm-hmm
and you know what they've said later you
know a SEAL team guy a Special
Operations guy said thank you and he
listened and that that was our attitude
we were so thankful and grateful that
you know you all helped us so much when
we got on the ground and just the the
the other thing you know we just had
complete respect and admiration as I
said in the beginning because look we're
looking at you get you know a lot of the
a lot of you all are looking at us like
oh these guys are highly trained and
we're looking back at you saying you put
in gunfights every day for the last 11
months you know so I can't say enough to
thank you and everybody from from that
brigade that was there on the ground
that welcomed us that didn't give us any
attitude that didn't give us any they
just wanted to help and it was just it
was an awesome thing to to be a part of
and to see
when so you guys know you're going into
a nightmare yeah when you got on the
ground like what was the first thing
that you said to yourself oh this is
real it's funny you know I had a
personal security detachment which was a
platoon out of the Nebraska National
Guard and the platoon leader awesome
leader Jacques Smith is a fantastic
lieutenant we were out and we and I was
out a lot okay but always with the
purpose I could tell you a little bit
background on that in a minute but we
were out there shortly after Hoover
there and I we have many IEDs used
against our particular Patrol but I D
detonates nobody was heard it was
relatively not significant and me and
Jacques look at each other and we go you
know there's actually people trying to
kill us you know and it's kind of like
yeah right reality set in very very
quickly and it was like like there's
people actually like trying to kill us
you know and I think that reality set in
for everybody pretty quickly how did you
what was your approach when you showed
up so by the time we got there in April
of a sex right you guys had really
secured like all the main MSR was going
in and out of the city yes what was your
what was your kind of larger operational
approach when you showed up yeah I'd say
it was a couple different phases the
first phase was really getting
situational understanding of what was
going on and the second Brigade 2nd
Infantry Division really helped us do
that then the phase after that I like to
think of as getting the it was a leader
engagement phase we're really trying to
get the shakes and government and the
governor probably remembered governor
the moon yeah to to really support our
effort there we saw we did not see many
Imams there to be honest with you it was
mainly the sheiks and the governor we
were dealing with and we made a lot of
headway there and then the phase after
that I like to call the murder and
intimidation phase where the insurgents
actually got the upper hand on murdering
key shakes which hurt our leader
engagement effort which had been
successful and then the last phase I
like to call suddeniy conditions for the
next Brigade to come through and that's
where we were trying to do our best to
set up combat outpost in certain areas
where we could then stay there now this
is the thing you may not know about our
brigade remember we had from Ramadi to
Hibernia in May of 2006 I was visited by
two very senior generals and the
question they asked what you need to
control Ramadi and Ramadi was very
chaotic at that time because of murder
intimidation and the lack of us able to
engage leaders very effectively because
of the murder intimidation of the sheiks
and what I explained to them is you
needed a brigade and Ramadi proper
itself if you want to control it a
brigade and habbaniyah and then another
brigade up in jazeera which was north of
the Euphrates River and the one general
put his head in his hand and just kind
of like shook his head and he said to
them to his senior he said sir
that's an entire division and at that
point in time they were trying to
downsize and he didn't push back on me
though he basically just realized that
couldn't do that one thing that happened
when we were leaving and the next
Brigade was coming in five five easting
which was just east of Camp Corregidor
and that's where their area of operation
ended so they didn't have habbaniyah so
the brigade after us came in with they
were able to put three additional
battalions into Ramadi
okay we didn't alright so they were able
to instead of putting a battalion and
habbaniyah they were able to put it in a
Ramadi and then they came in with two
additional battalion headquarters
besides that mm-hmm
so they had from what I understand they
had three additional battalion
headquarters one full battalion plus
plus another four companies so one of
the reasons think things started to
change is because they were able to mass
more troops in that area and as a
difference between fighting a
large-scale combat operation and
fighting an insurgency and a large-scale
combat operation you don't want to mass
troops you want to mass effects of your
combat power you think you know if
you're fighting a near-peer where appear
you don't want to mass troops you want
to mass the effects of combat power when
you're fighting an insurgency that's
where you want to mass troops and I
think what the coin doctrine came out
with was was one counter insurgent for
every 20 civilians that are in that city
and Ramadi had a population of around
400,000 we had nowhere near what the
coin doctrine called for so we were
struggling with that so I believed in
the hamburger hill principle of never
ordering a patrol to go into an area
that we were prepared to put a combat
outpost in and stay in I saw it as
stupid to send a patrol into an area for
two or three hours just to do with
friggin patrol and come right back out
again because I could I could deal with
losing a soldier or marine if there was
a purpose a good purpose to lose that
soldier marine I I'd I'd have a hard
time explaining to a mother or father
why their marine or soldier got killed
for just the sake of going in there for
three hours and coming back out again if
it was to put a combat outpost in I
could accept that you see what I'm
saying so when I say the hamburger hill
concept cuz you know hamburger
and then leave right it's kind of like
why the hell you want to do that and I
was dead set against that yeah and I
think that's well well once the one:1
showed up they had enough people that we
could go in you set up a combat outpost
and then what you're doing is patrolling
to clear bad guys because you're there
and it's a different game you know you
mentioned the murder and intimidation of
the sheiks and this was all happening I
mean I arrived in May yes I arrived in
May and so this was kind of was it still
happening I remember we're reading the
Intel reports and and from what I
remember there was like one 48-hour
period or one very short period of time
where seven or eight senior sheiks were
murdered and the rest of them almost all
of the rest of them well a large portion
of the rest of them left the this is
what happened in probably around the
September timeframe and I'd be talking
to the governor in the shakes
about once a week starting in September
they started to see that a lot of what
they were telling us we were starting to
change the way we conducted operations
I'll give you an example when I first
got there we would send patrols into
homes without Intel just to search the
homes so how would you like it if you're
in a house but you're your wife and two
kids and all of a sudden this army
patrol comes in and says you know what
just for the hell of it we're gonna
start you know looking through the
drawers in your bedroom dresser you know
and so the shakes we're complaining
about that it's like you know what that
makes sense to me so I said to our guys
listen we're not going to go in and do a
search of a home unless there's targeted
intelligence that gives us a reason to
because otherwise we're just making
enemies of good people and turning
neutrals to be helping the insurgents
you don't want to do that so you know
that was one example there was another
outpost that we had north of Corregidor
up by a hospital that was up in that
area
which I took down in the main reason I
took that down because I didn't want to
drive that row you know I didn't want to
drive that route because you're get
blown up because we were we were having
our soldiers get killed driving up there
and it's like you know what this makes
no sense take it down the cool thing is
is the shakes have been asking me to
take that down so when I took it down I
told the shakes the reason we took this
down is because you wanted better access
to the hospital without your civilian
you know your Iraqi civilians going
through two checkpoints so they saw that
as wow if this guy listen to me what was
the outcome the outcome is in the
elections in December where in January
2005 two percent of the citizens of
Ramadi voted in an election in December
2005 80% of the Iraqis voted in the
election the sheiks were encouraging
them to vote mm-hm and so we saw that as
men we turn to current a corner the
other thing is we were trying to recruit
Iraqi police because we knew we had to
get Iraqi police to to agree to join and
then to go through the training so we
would have recruiting events and we were
getting two or three Iraqis to show up
to the recruiting event and join until
January January third we had this
recruiting event at the glass factory
200 Iraqis standing in line to join
that's only because of the shake
encouragement January 4th we had about
500 Iraqis standing in front of the gap
glass factory to join man we were
ecstatic
yeah and just to give a little bit more
detail just to re-emphasize what you
said these are 500 local citizens that
our tribal tribesmen wear the tribal
leaders are directing them hey looks
like the coalition looks like the
Americans they've kind
we're getting on board go down and join
the police so we can get rid of
insurgents in this city the biggest
mistake I made was I did it a third day
in a row and on January 5th I think you
know what happened to suicide bomber
detonated his vest in the middle of a
thousand Iraqis who were there that day
I mean we were ecstatic we had a
thousand Iraqi showing up the joint
when months before he we had two or
three I mean this this was a turning
point so the suicide bomber detonates
their vest kills at least a hundred
Iraqi city citizens kills my best friend
Mike McLaughlin who was my leader
engagement officer and killed sergeant
cann who was a Marine dog handler and
wounds several other soldiers but not
now you know seriously and but any wound
is serious if you get wounded I guess
and totally disrupted the whole thing
the thing I was proud of with a though
is the Iraqis we already had inside the
glass factory we continued to process
them what I did the next day and again
we were devastated by this what I did
the next day I called all the leaders
involved with that recruiting operation
because that was a battalion plus
operation and pulled us off got all the
leaders in I said listen we're going to
do an after-action review a lessons
learned thing on this and I said before
anybody says anything and I know you
know your book extreme ownership talks
about this not not this exact incident
but in general I said before anybody
says anything I said I'm the guy
responsible for that attack yesterday I
said so this review this after-action
review isn't going to have anything to
do with putting blame on anybody because
it's my fault this is what happened I
said what we're going to do is we got to
figure out we got 200 Iraqis showing up
next week to get on buses so we could
transport them to the police training I
said we got to figure out how do we make
this safe a week from now safer a week
from
so the same thing doesn't happen again
and so we took some specific tactical
measures to make it much safer one of
the things we did we got these big Texas
barricades and we formed up ten
different stalls we're only ten people
at a time could fit inside of a stall so
if a suicide bomber did detonate their
vest the most they could kill is nine
other people instead of a hundred you
see what I'm saying and then we set up
some other measures I don't want to get
into the detail on this podcast because
it's not important the point is is that
we made it safer the next week even
after this devastating attack where a
hundred Iraqis were killed and some of
my soldiers were killed we still have
those two hundred policemen showing 200
civilians showing up to go to police
training that next week and then the
thing that happened that was exactly
what you said when they saw that they
couldn't stop these young people these
young men these young Iraqis coming in
to continue to see the process through
that's when they started to murder the
sheiks and that's what cut out our
leader engagement completely because
these sheiks used to come to the
government center once a week to talk to
me
zero showed up once they started getting
murdered they weren't showing up so the
thing we were not able to do was protect
those shakes and and that's what really
caused a lot of the turmoil to occur up
to the point where you guys got there
I've heard Mike McLaughlin McLaughlin
Mike McLaughlin yeah Mike McLaughlin
Mike McLaughlin I've heard him referred
to as the shake of shakes you know he
was one of these guys that kind of got
it absolutely and was making friends and
he was that kind of guy he was he owned
his own construction business he was a
field artillery officer and since we had
the triple deuce from the Utah National
Guard as the GS artillery battalion you
know I had this extra Field Artillery
Lieutenant Colonel there and so I made
him my leader engagement officer
he was just this type of guy being a
businessman talking about using National
Guard civilian skills you know he's an
entrepreneur he was just able to connect
with all these different Iraqis he used
to say that Ramadi because of you Fraidy
is River and the I think was the Nasser
canal running into your freight ease
River
he said that reminded him of Pittsburgh
you know what the rivers running
together so he told everybody he told
all these Iraqis that you know someday
Ramadi is going to be like Pittsburgh
and I'm gonna come back and visit you
know I'm gonna bring my wife and kids
back here yeah how long after the glass
factory bombing so then the the recruits
start showing up again young insurgents
realize oh we haven't broken their will
yet we got to start killing the shakes
was that a week later two weeks later
I'd say was within four you know I don't
have this on the tip of my memory but it
was probably within about four weeks I
the Intel that I remember was I think it
was seven or eight of the main sheiks
got murdered yes and then the other
sheiks most of them just fled they went
to ground
yeah they either flat or went to ground
and other the other reason why Ramadi
was so dysfunctional is right when the
war started there were some like really
heavy-duty main sheiks living in Ramadi
they all went to Jordan
so the sheiks that were left in Ramadi
for the sub sheiks so but they were
still the power brokers there but they
just weren't as powerful as the sheiks
who actually left the country but uh but
even you know like it like you said you
know they they got murdered and that
really that really changed things
because now the the sheiks were not
cooperating with us like they had they
just kind of went to ground and were
neutralized and really that's the
purpose I mean that's that's that's
that's terror right we are going to
terrorize you to the point where you no
longer will step up right and that's
exactly what happened that was
the al-qaeda in Iraq segment who is
doing that because do you know it as you
as you know you know you being there
there there were different segments of
the insurgency one was a qiz al-qaeda in
Iraq the other one was the local
insurgents about a different goal than
al-qaeda in Iraq the local insurgents
just wanted coalition forces to leave we
could deal with them you know cuz we
could let them know that hey you you
know when things settle down here when
you get enough of your own sons and
Iraqi police we will leave we'll be glad
to leave that's a good deal you want us
to leave we want to leave exact let's
figure this out and then you had the
criminal element and then you also you
know in the criminal element they were
just concerned with making money by
selling weapons and then you also have
this fourth contingent there who were
former Iraqi generals they knew where
the ordnance was hidden you know there
were caches all over the place they knew
where they were ahead and they knew to
the terrain and they wanted to regain
their status and power again that was
there that was their goal you mentioned
this very briefly but you know you just
meant being out and I remember being out
on an operation somewhere and there you
are you know there's a brigade commander
walking down the street and you you just
said you were gonna mention a little bit
about what that mentality was I mean I'm
pretty sure I know what it is because I
did the same things like sometimes I was
going on operations with my troops
because I need to go on operations with
the troops
was that a similar mindset that you had
yeah
I mean you could only learn so much from
hearing reports you got to get out there
and see things with your own eyes that
was one reason the other reason is it
did a lot for morale you know when the
soldiers saw that I hate the commander's
out there they feel like somebody is
sharing a load and in order to build
trust that you know when I talk a lot
about building trust and one of the the
keys to building trust is to share the
load to this show whoever is working for
you that you're willing to do the same
thing they're doing and so those were
the two reasons I felt it was very
important to get out there but you know
I read this book it was called the clay
pigeons of saint-lo oh yeah you've
covered it on this podcast right here
great great over John Glover John's who
was also a hero in the Korean War - yeah
by the way but I read that book and one
thing Glover John's talked about in that
book is when he was going with his
little command group from point A to
point B and he had his radio operator
with him and he had his s3 with him and
s2 or whoever he had with him in that
command group from that battalion
headquarters he decided one day to go
from point A to point B without a reason
to do that and mortars came in and
killed about three or four of his
soldiers in that command group and he
wrote in the book how it light bulb went
off in his head that hey when I make a
decision to go from point A to point B
it's just not my life I'm putting on the
line I'm putting the life of my command
group on the line too that the guys who
are traveling with me so because I read
that I I said to myself I am never gonna
go from point A to point B just to do a
joyride through Ramadi whenever I take
my PSD out me out with me my personal
security detachment a bunch of III Zandi
fours and E fives if they were going to
get killed because I was going from
point A to point B I wanted them there
to be a reason for them to die and if so
I had to go somewhere with a purpose and
I was out a lot because I had a lot of
reasons to be out there but I would
never ever go out just for a joyride
because that that's not what because I
was one of those soldiers at risk every
time I went out how was it you know you
show up and there was already a marine
battalion already there yeah one one
five who excellent combat leader
battalion commander who is now a
three-star general still serving in the
Marines
matter of fact all three marine
battalions who serve with me because
they were on seven-month rotations so
the one five was there they served with
me for two months then the three seven
came in and served with me for seven
months and then the three eight came in
all three of those battalion commanders
are general officers now you know the
Marine Corps is a small Corps and if
you're going to be
an infantry battalion commander in the
Marines you got to have your shit
together they don't put anybody in
charge of a Marine infantry battalion
and and all three of those commanders
were excellent was there any time you
know people always talk about the the
competition between the army the Marine
Corps I'm not even gonna say Navy
because the Navy makes up such a small
element but you know the Army and Marine
Corps I I always tell anyone and as a
matter of fact it's sort of a point for
me if anybody ever tries to you know get
me to say something about the army of
the Marine Corps I won't say I won't I
won't say a negative comment not even in
a joking manner I won't do it because of
what I saw over there what I saw from
those soldiers what I saw from those
Marines did you feel the same thing just
nothing but you know nothing but nothing
but let's work together to get this done
yeah absolutely and I feel the same way
about you I will not joke about another
service one thing I learned over there
even from the Army you know a lot of
times in our if your infantry you know
you think all the other branches don't
matter and I kind of have that attitude
before going over there to a degree and
one thing I learned is every branch
matters significantly every MOS of any
soldier I mean it's all such an
important team and in terms you know
answer your question with the Marines
man I just learned to respect those
Marines so much they respected us you
know I was a little bit concerned here I
am a National Guard brigade commander
and now I've got an active-duty marine
battalion task organized in my brigade
and I have an active duty army battalion
when I first got there was 269 armor
before first of the 506 got there I'm
thinking man what are these active duty
battalion commanders gonna think of a
National Guard brigade commander they
showed me nothing but respect and I
think that's the way you got to do it
you you have to personally I think you
know if you're going to work with
anybody in the military you have to come
come from the perspective that these
guys are professional they know their
business until they give you a reason
the
differently you know and and I feel that
way about trust too and a lot of people
don't understand this at first but you
know in order to create trust in an
organization I think you have to trust
your followers first before they will
trust you and the question I like to ask
people is is this I say have you ever
worked for somebody that didn't trust
you and people will say yeah you know
there's an occasion where I work for
somebody who didn't trust me I said were
you able to trust that person and the
answer is always no how could you trust
somebody who doesn't trust you so if I'm
a leader and I don't trust my
subordinates if I just come in with
attitude I'm not going to trust you
until you prove you could I could trust
you how they gonna trust me because you
cannot trust somebody who doesn't trust
you so you have to trust others first
but again those those battalion
commanders from all three marine
battalions all two army towns with
active duty units that worked with me
showed nothing but respect and trust of
me and thank God I never did anything to
to do anything that caused them not to
trust me so I I'm just I'm just so
thankful that I had such professionals
to work with over there and then of
course the battalion commanders from the
National Guard units that were with me
you know I had National Guard battalion
from Vermont who we never worked with
before those tasks organized to me from
Utah with the field artillery unit that
was task organized to - my Brigade and
everybody just came together and again I
think because it was so violent there
people just knew the hey we got to do
our jobs you know and it's funny after
coming back and continuing in the Army
in a non wartime environment it's funny
how that add to changes a little bit
when you're in a peacetime setting I've
heard you tell a story about one of your
one of your Marines eld guys and really
just an I would love for you to be able
to share that story and I think you know
the one I'm talking yeah yeah absolutely
this happened on September 19 2005 and I
actually earlier that morning we had one
of our soldiers killed he was a driver
of a Bradley Fighting Vehicle ie went up
underneath the driver's compartment of
his Bradley and he was killed and later
on that day we had a patrol under the
command of a lieutenant from the Vermont
National Guard who was conducting a
patrol down at the Tamim area of Ramadi
and you may recall there was a railroad
bridge down there and we had an outpost
of that railroad bridge that didn't
exist before we got there the brigade
that was there before us just didn't
have the what it took to get down there
and put that outpost in but we put the
outpost in and then we had to secure
that area to keep the lines of
communication operational so we could
rotate troops in a now get Allah just
down there get a QRF down there whenever
we had to a Quick Reaction Force and so
anyway we had this lieutenant from the
Vermont National Guard patrolling that
area and for up-armored Humvees and he
began to get insurgent fire from round
by the railroad bed and so he ordered
his platoon which was for up-armored
Humvees to start maneuvering toward that
insurgent position so they could close
with them and destroy them and as he was
maneuvering in his vehicle a subsurface
ID detonated that had proudly been there
maybe about a year in the ground I don't
know you know some of these IDs have
been planted there for months and ID
detonates and instantly kills the
lieutenant and the two soldiers who were
in that up-armored Humvee with them and
some 3ki a instantly and whenever we
would have attacks like this we would
try to whenever we could send our aod
team down to do a post blast analysis to
determine the type of tactics
type of ordinance the type of procedures
the insurgents were using when they
conducted these attacks and we reason we
did that does try to prevent these
attacks from happening again in the
future and so a gunnery sergeant Michael
Burkhart was the gunnery sergeant who
led two other Marines down to that site
and it was chaotic down there you know
but our guys were providing security the
gun he gets down there with the two
fellow Marines and he sees the destroyed
up armored Humvee and near the
up-armored hmmwv he sees this crater a
couple feet deep about four feet in
diameter he just made an assumption that
that's where the ID had been placed so
he jumps down in the crater to take a
closer look and as soon as he was in the
crater he realized he wasn't in a good
place because he saw to 152 millimeter
artillery shells in the ground in front
of him would read that nation cord
running into the nose of those shells so
he took his k-bar knife cut the red det
cord believed he'd neutralized the ID he
didn't see a third artillery shell in
the crater behind him the devices those
insurgents used there were Sanae Oh base
stations which were high powered
cordless phones they use them a lot in
Africa like in villages to get telephone
reception within their village so it's a
it's a very high-powered cordless phone
base and they would they would strap
that base to the artillery shell and
then use a cordless phone about a
kilometer away the usually had about a
kilometer distance they would hit the
button on that detonation device to
cause the ID to explode an insurgent was
obviously out there in the distance
watching hit the button on that
detonation device artillery shell blows
up and back a Gunny Burkhardt knocks him
about 15 feet into the air lands
unconscious on the ground like a rag
doll our soldiers go immediately up to
him they believe the wounds were very
very severe they called in a medevac
helicopter and they start tending to his
wounds as pants were soaked with blood
that cut his pants off he's unconscious
after a couple of minutes they actually
regains consciousness he's laying there
on his back
and he asked the soldiers if he has his
legs because he has no feeling from the
waist down he thought he had both legs
blown off but the soldiers assured him
he had his legs the reason he was
concerned about his legs and he told me
that this himself is his dad
served three tours in Vietnam on his
dad's third tour in Vietnam his dad was
shot in the back by a sniper Gunny
Burkhart had to grow up as a young boy
with the pain of seeing his father
confined to a wheelchair because his dad
was paralyzed from the waist down
Gandhi's worst nightmare was going back
home to the States because his dad was
still alive and his dad seeing him also
confined to a wheelchair that's why he
was concerned about his legs but anyway
they said no you got your legs
a few minutes go by they're tending to
him he gets a tingling sensation in his
legs he tells the soldiers he wants to
try to stand up and the soldiers
couldn't believe this and he stands up
and after only just getting blown up ten
minutes earlier and we had a embed
reporter from the Omaha world-herald on
the ground with them that day Gunny
Burkhart stands up and the medevac
chopper lands on the ground behind him
and the soldiers go to a Gunny burkhart
they go Gunny
we got the stretcher here lay on the
stretcher so we could carry you to the
chopper and Burkhart raises his left
hand into the air throws a one-finger
salute at the insurgents and he says
that the soldiers I'm not gonna lie I'm
not going to have you carry me to that
chopper on the stretcher I'm gonna walk
there under my own power because I don't
want the insurgents to have the pleasure
of seeing me being carried to the
helicopter and he throws him the finger
and the reporter takes the picture at
that exact second so there's Burkhart
finger in the air defiant groin
protector in front of his groin no pants
on and and the reporter takes this
picture and later on that day the
reporter comes in to see me because he
had been on the ground with us for
almost a month and he comes in to see me
has a little laptop with him and he goes
he goes sir he goes I know it's been a
really bad day for you obviously I lost
four soldiers that day he goes but I
want to show you this picture
he goes I won't release it unless you
give me permission he lifts up his
laptop screen he pulls up the picture in
that picture that picture is across the
entire laptop screen I look at that I
said you got us you got to get this in
the paper I said you got to get this in
the paper and the rest of the leadership
story with Connie Burkhart is this
though because you know it's a cool war
story okay except for the fact that we
have these soldiers die but the the
leadership component of the story as I
told you he had two young Marines down
there with them that day Gunny Burkhart
told me himself the reason he didn't
want to be carried of that chopper had
nothing at all to do with that with
insurgents would be thinking he knew
what all the idea attacks we were
getting that those two young Marines
were going to be out there later on that
day neutralizing IEDs he knew he was
going to have to be recovering from
those wounds he wanted to walk there to
the helicopter as to not shatter the
confidence of those two young Marines
that were out there with them so the
leadership element of the story is even
after getting blown up ten minutes
earlier
his main concern wasn't with his own
wounds his main concern was with the
confidence of those two young Marines
that he knew was going to be out there
later on neutralizing IEDs so even after
getting blown up his main concern was
with those two young Marines who work
for him and isn't that what leadership
is all about worrying more about the
guys who follow you than you worry about
yourself I just think it's an
inspirational story we have very few
politicians coming to visit us or quote
VIPs coming to visit us in Ramadi but
whenever we did if I had a brief from
the first slide I showed him was gonna
Burkhart throw on the finger of those in
the some of the other things that are
happening is you're spending a bunch of
money trying to you know the provincial
reconstruction and development tell us a
little bit about that yeah we had we had
a lot of money to to dole out and this
was that this was the issue
we had nobody from the State Department
there with us until I think that last
month before we left because it was so
violent so we didn't really have that
State Department support and whenever we
would thik whenever we would give money
to the Iraqis to fix the school or a
water plant or whatever then surgeons
would destroy it so we didn't really do
that well with with wood fixing
infrastructure there in Ramadi and as
you could probably remember there was
sewage running down the streets all the
time because of the the roadside bombs
that were blowing up and breaking sewer
pipes and everything else so we did do
our best to get in the schools we had
patrols going into schools all the time
passing out stuff that the kids I was in
schools many it was it's kind of weird
environment there because some days well
not some days every day you knew you
were going to have a high probability of
getting shot at or blown up and yet we
tried to create some normalcy especially
with the kids there and and so it was a
it was really weird in that way you know
we're talking about extreme ownership a
little bit earlier and you know the the
I opened it up talking about a blue on
blue that we had you were there at the
time and I know there was a lot of
different stuff going on and it probably
didn't even make the radar of what you
had seen and what you were dealing with
but and and it was weird for me because
you know in the SEAL Teams having a blue
on blue is it seems like the most
impossible thing that could ever occur
you know how could it possibly happen
that one a good guy shoots a good guy
how is that possible and so in my chain
of command after that happened that
happened very early in deployment for me
to try and explain to people that
this this happens this happens a lot in
this environment what was how often were
you seeing those situations unfold yeah
first let me say in the army just like
in the SEALs we take blue and blue very
seriously as a matter of fact even in
training events if there's a if we're
doing a warfighter exercise which is a
computer-generated exercise if there's a
blue on blue event and the warfighter
it's got to be investigated that's how
seriously we take it I saw blue on blue
more often than I would have thought and
it was primarily units passing through
another units area of operation where
the you know the unit passing through
wasn't clear on where certain combat
outpost or observation posts were set up
and they would see what looked like you
know again a soldier with a weapon in
the sand and I know you talked about in
your book with with Chris Kyle actually
know where that happens I remember an
interesting situation I'll just mention
to you
we had a patrol down in Tamim which is
in southern Ramadi and they were you
know conducting their operations down
there dealing with Iraqi citizens and
talking to them and and such and then
there was a civil affairs team that was
not part of my brigade that was also in
that vicinity and there was some small
arms fire and the unit from my brigade
that felt that there was an insurgents
up on top of a rooftop and this is very
similar to a story you tell and the
commander on the ground wanted a Super
Cobra since the Marines were supporting
us not in Apache but a Super Cobra fire
on the rooftop at what he thought were
insurgents up there and I happened to be
in the Operations Center at the time and
I guess it's just over time to get some
type of intuition something just did not
seem right and
the fire that this patrol was under
wasn't really that significant where I
felt it wasn't you know life-threatening
to that patrol and I said you know let's
just let this play out a little bit more
let's do some tactical patience here and
let this play out a little bit more
before I give an order for a Super Cobra
to fire on that target as it turned out
it was the Civil Affairs team on that
roof and and I just thank God I just
thank God that God gave me the presence
of mind to to wait a little bit and just
see how things develop before pulling
the trigger on that thing
so it's it's you just have to again use
you know real big in the army you know
especially when you're a lieutenant or
something yeah hey you got to make a
decision
you know I talked about making decisions
quickly sometimes the best decision to
make is let me use some tactical
patience so let me just see how this
plays out a little bit until I get a
little bit more information before I
pull the trigger on something yeah the
other part of that is not not getting
emotional because as you know and I
thought about earlier I think before we
even started recording is a lot of times
you wouldn't see who is attacking you
right and you're losing guys guys are
getting wounded guys are getting killed
and now all of a sudden someone's
telling you we see the bad guys it's
it's hard not to just have an emotional
moment to say hey oh there's bad guys
there let's get them yes and you have to
take a moment to make sure that the
decision you're making is the right
decision and and like you said sometimes
it's a pause and I've been talking about
this a lot lately so one of the
principles of leadership that I talk
about all the time is default aggressive
which means you're gonna make something
happen make it happen like you don't
wait but there's if you pay attention to
that term default aggressive it's the
default mode it's not it's not the
mandatory mode it can be overruled it
can be overridden the the Marine Corps
just came out with a new book called
learning
and and one of the one of the terms that
they use throughout the book is they try
to train Marines to have a bias for
action same thing it's not blind action
it's not take immediate action no matter
what it's lean towards taking action
that's the same thing with default
aggressive it's hey your your default
mode is I'm gonna be aggressive
that doesn't mean you are necessarily
going to be aggressive yeah and you know
when you're engaged in fighting a
counterinsurgency the other thing is you
don't you don't want to kill an
insurgent at the expense of killing
innocent civilians and that's you know
from reading history since I was a
teenager
especially World War two history you
know all of the civilians that were
killed during World War two
and I remember when I first got to
Ramadi this is how I had learned as I
was there you know we talk about
continuous learning as I would say that
a sheiks hey this this is a battle going
on here civilians are going to die you
got to accept that they didn't want to
accept that that that was their
tribesmen you know they don't want to
accept that yeah these civilians are
gonna die and I learned through the
course of time there that we had to do
if we wanted to win this thing we had to
do all we could do to not kill innocent
Iraqi citizens and if that meant not
killing an insurgent in order to save
three innocent citizens you were better
you were better - I felt you were better
to operate that way yeah I think that's
the that's the standard that's the
standard that's what that's that's the
American yeah way and that you know
that's another thing and we've talked I
talked about this a little bit and this
is I don't like to get wrapped up in in
you know people that are gonna argue
political points about you know the way
things unfolded that the way things
unfolded right but one of the things
that you hear a lot is people will talk
about yeah you know what I'm when I say
this I'm really talking about there's
people that just look at the Iraq war as
this complete horrible thing everything
was wrong and one of the things that
they say all the time is that
all these civilians died and and
something that I try and point out to
people all the time is yes you're right
civilians died and yes Americans did
kill some of those civilians but we went
through extreme measures and took
extreme risks always to prevent any
civilian casualties and the amount of
civilians that Americans actually killed
is not a big number the reason that the
number of civilians killed is so large
is because of the insurgents and because
of the the fighting that took place in
the you know Hsieh versus Zuni for
instance it really the amount of
civilians killed by Americans is a very
small number when you compare it to what
the insurgents did to the people of Iraq
no I absolutely agree on you know I mean
it is our values and the thing I'm most
proud of the Marines and soldiers I
worked with over there in the seals I
worked with over there is that Heron
stew our military values and to our
American values of of doing just that
taking great pains not to kill a
civilian even at the risk of not killing
a bad guy so very very proud of a quick
story I want to share with you the
governor that we talked about dealt with
him a lot he had to have a medical
procedure conducted at one point in time
so since Ramadi was so dysfunctional and
chaotic we had to send him to Baghdad to
an American military treatment facility
in Baghdad he was gone about two weeks
for this medical procedure he comes back
and sends a message that he wants to see
me so I go see I go see him and he asked
everybody in the office to leave you
know you usually have this on trays of
shakes and there he and his staff
everybody left except him me and my
interpreter he sits down besides me
first time he takes my hand in his and
for anybody knows anything about Arab
culture when a Arab man takes another
man's hand and his it's a sign of trust
and respect first time he ever did that
and he said you know Colonel gronski
many times you have sat here you've
talked to me about American values and
the values of the Marines and soldiers I
never knew what you were trying to tell
me but he said when I was at that
American medical treatment facility in
Baghdad I watched with my own eyes how a
wounded insurgent was brought in to the
trauma center there and I saw how your
American medics and nurses and doctors
struggled to saved the life of this
insurgent and he said I could not
believe how hard you Americans worked to
save the life of one of your enemies
he said now I finally realize what you
were trying to tell me about American
values and I mean that really hit home
that he saw with his own eyes how we
treated our enemies fighting to save the
life of this insurgent from a from a
leadership perspective and really from a
personal perspective as well I mean I
know there was months where you lost
boss took very significant casualties
you know and and when I look at the
glass factory and what it just it just
insane setback and even hearing you talk
about it earlier when we weren't
recording you know just the be you know
that that for you seeing the local
populace showing up I mean this is the
this is the dream for for a
counterinsurgency is that we're going to
get the local populace they're gonna
take to the streets and clean up the
insurgents and this is how we win and
all of a sudden in a matter of days a
pathway to victory is actually visible
and then to have that horrible incident
take place losing you know your your
best friend over there and yet you still
have to press on what what is it about
how do you do that mentally how do you
get up how do you move forward when you
take these significant setbacks
you know Jocko I think the answer is
pretty simple
it's because especially when you're in a
leadership position you've got others
counting on you so because you've got
others counting on you you have no
choice but to continue to even in
situations like that to try to be as
positive as you could you know one thing
I did over there because you know the
days over there could seem like
Groundhog Day to the average soldier out
there on a patrol day after day you know
seeing you know these Iraqis give him
the stink eye and all that and and
having his buddy killed and wounded and
all of that Groundhog Day I actually put
out what I called success cards on a
monthly basis because the average
soldier didn't understand the success we
were having and had to be communicated
to the average soldier marine so what
would be on the success card okay we
found this many weapons caches this
month we detained this many high-value
target insurgents this month we actually
did engagements in this many schools
this month etc etc so there was always
something to be able to communicate that
you succeeded on that if you were just
the average soldier out there doing your
job day after day you might not have
seen that but I think people have to
understand when they're in a situation
like that leaders have to have a way to
communicate the bigger picture to their
followers so they understand you are
making progress because otherwise it
could seem like you're not but can
answer your question I think it's just
about the fact that people are counting
on you you got to do your job
mm-hmm as you guys are nearing the end
of deployment I show up their task unit
bruiser one of the first things that we
start planning for is like a Fallujah
style clearance of Ramadi and the plan
as I understood it and again it's a loop
seems like a long time ago in some ways
and this is one of those ways trying to
remember exactly but the plan that as I
remembered is we were starting to
organize this thing was that wall when
the one one ad showed up and we have the
two to eight and the one one ad on the
ground at the same time we got double
the combat power
we're gonna do a massive push through
and I was telling my guys from a
political standpoint it made sense to me
because this is why I told my guys I
said look I think this is gonna happen
and the reason I think it's gonna happen
is because Maliki who just is the prime
minister and he's a Shia and this is a
city filled with Sunni people and I bet
he's gonna say yep go for it I happen to
be wrong and Maliki was a lot smarter
and was a lot a lot more willing to try
and work towards a stable Iraq because
he realized that no actually we're not
going to do that there's too much death
there's too much destruction it will
look exactly like what it is which is a
big Shia army push into a city filled
with Sunnis and a bunch of soon he's
getting displaced and it'll be bad
I actually on one of my podcast was
discussing this with one of my friends
Daryl and he had read some information
that that was all the the the plan for a
big push through was actually kind of a
feint to try and get insurgents to leave
and I don't know if it's true or not I
don't know if you know it's true or not
what what do you remember about that
yeah I remember there was talk about it
but the other crazy thing there was talk
about not having a brigade come in to do
a relief with us a serious talk about
when two to eight leaves there's not
going to be another brigade there so
there was so it went from one extreme
that other I did hear talk about a major
push and I you know through the city to
quote clean it out and then I heard talk
that there there may not be another
brigade to come in actually the brigade
that ended up coming in there wasn't
really identified until shortly before
we we left so I think it was a lot of
leaders from both sides Iraq and and and
the United States trying to figure out
what the best course was and it was a
very complex situation very chaotic and
I think they were just trying to really
figure it out I was in in between my
first
to Iraq and my second deployment to Iraq
I was the Admirals aide so I worked for
the Admiral in charge of all the seals
great guy and that put me in a lot of
meetings a lot of meetings that uh oh
three would never be in some of those
meetings in the Pentagon in with with
the the highest you know the highest
leaders in the military and I saw that I
saw that there was people inside the
military that were wondering if we could
win and wondering how we could win if we
could win you know the the report that
came out in in that that summer know six
what said we can't win
it's unwinnable an unwinnable situation
so the idea that that both those options
were on the board actually kind of makes
sense because you had I guarantee you
had some people saying we can't win we
can't win in that area and then and and
obviously some people saying hey we can
we just need to get the combat power
that's needed and we need to commit to
it yeah so you know there's an old
saying you can't kill yourself out of an
insurgency you know you can't kill
enough insurgents there's always going
to be more insurgents and even my
mindset changed while I was there
initially when we went in our mission
statement was to defeat the the
insurgency take away their will to fight
and it actually evolved into protecting
the populace and there's a big
difference between hey let's see how
many insurgents who killed versus hey
let's protect the population and to
protect the population you need a
certain amount of mass of troops there
and I do think what happened when when
the follow mine Brigade came in they
they did it they were able to mass more
troops which is great and I give all the
soldiers and Marines credit for for the
great work they did with - - with 2nd
Brigade 28th ID and then with with
already first I mean the credit belongs
to the average soldier marine that was
out
slogging slogging it out everyday the
average seal that was out there doing
their job every day and not giving up
yeah I mean they I mean there's this is
a perfect example of resiliency even
with those odds stacked against us our
soldiers and Marines just would not give
up yeah we might ask unit what was good
about my task you know and I think what
was really appreciated was we could kill
those bad guys and we could kill those
bad guys and it was you know you could
see you know you talked to a company
commander any one of those company
commanders that weren't out there they'd
go out they'd get in patrol they'd get
in a gunfight they'd shoot it some
people they wouldn't really know we
would leave dead bodies in the streets
of the insurgents and and it was of the
insurgents and that just seemed to be a
really good asset and something that
made the made the conventional guys and
they were they were so happy when we'd
show up at one of their one of their
combat outposts they would be so happy
for us to show up there cuz they knew
that they'd send out a patrol and they'd
get in a gunfight for sure and sometimes
they'd kill a bad guy but they knew that
we would we would rack up these kills
and what's what's good about it is it
allowed us to eliminate the bad guys
while protecting the pop the populace so
it was a great tool in this environment
to help out and and that was you know
that's that's one of the main things
that that people talk to me about is you
know how do you build relationships
right and how do you build relationships
with people and for me it's real simple
you build a relationship by saying how
can I help you and and that's why when I
walked into your office and you've got
you know was 6,000 I guess you include
Iraqis 10,000 troops there and I'm not
thinking about me and what can I do I'm
thinking what how can I help you and
that's the attitude and that's the same
attitude we took with the one 180 when
they showed up it wasn't hey we
here it was what can we do to help you
how can we what do you need from us how
can we be of assistance and and then the
relationship is oh we can definitely use
your help and then guess what they give
back to us help so it's pretty um yeah
you know jack a lot of things go through
my mind as you're talking and again you
had that great attitude of how could i
how could I help I remember when 269
Armour left they were with me for the
first six months we were there and then
first of the 506 comes in so what's the
difference between two six nine armor
and first out of 506 you're talking
about an armored battalion versus a
light infantry battalion okay so you
know just because 269 was rotating out
doesn't mean they didn't need tanks
there so this is a great story about
resilience I guess you could call it
with with this national guard platoon
that I had working with 269 armor it was
a was a platoon from an armored unit in
the 28th id platoon of soldiers so that
was I think we had about 40 soldiers
there and they were tankers though but
when they get to 269 armor in East
Ramadi to work with them that I tasks
organized them to actually I task
organize an entire company their armored
company and but but to 69 armor didn't
need them to be armor soldiers they said
hey you guys be motorized infantry
because we got enough armored soldiers
so that's what they were until two six
nine are more leaves and then the first
of the five first ever 506 comes in and
they said we still need tanks so we took
a platoon from this armored company put
them on tanks because they were trained
tankers and they just talk about
pivoting okay we're talking about
pivoting with kovat 90 these guys
pivoted from being tankers to being
motorized infantry while two six nine
armored was there and then first out of
five or six different tree comes in they
pivot back to being tankers get on tanks
and did just a fabulous job and they had
several main gun engagements in downtown
Ramadi while they were working with
first of the 506
the first of 506 love them I forget one
month it was but I know there was a ie D
that destroyed a tank in the malabo area
would you talk about you know where
soccer stadium was and the tank
commander was able to get all of his
crewmen out of that tank without anybody
getting wounded were worse and there was
a fight that went on down there for at
least 24 hours and a few soldiers were
killed during that engagement from from
the first and 506 and and but it just
goes to show how these soldiers are so
adaptable so agile able to pivot like
that without complaining it's kind of
like this what you need us to do we'll
do it then Adam isn't that amazing story
though how many how many soldiers from
other armies couldn't make that type of
pivot and do it in an outstanding manner
like those soldiers that yeah it's just
that it shows you the the power of the
American military to have that kind of
attitude you know cuz it's it's
interesting as you say that hey how many
people could pivot and you're just
talking about the pivot you're not even
talking about the fact that these guys
are doing combat operation after combat
operation after combat operation in the
Milaap district with subsurface IEDs
destroying tanks destroying Humvees you
know these these coordinated attacks
that they're doing the vehicle-borne
IEDs I mean you were talking about the
the checkpoint on the railroad you know
right right in between Tamim and and and
south-central Ramadi that is one of that
is that is a checkpoint that got overrun
yeah it got overrun by the enemy massive
Iraqi soldiers killed and wounded most
of the Iraqi soldiers deserted after
that never came back but that's the kind
of the the enemy there was really good
yeah and they used the same they they
use combined arms you know between RPGs
and mortars and machine guns and then
vehicle-borne IEDs they coordinated over
the radio they had medevac procedures I
mean they
what what military units did yeah it was
a military unit and and they had a goal
of creating a Caliphate I mean that was
their goal you know talk about purpose
you know talk about inspiring people by
giving them a purpose that that was
their purpose in life was to create was
to take over Ramadi so they could have
that as part of what they thought would
be an emergent caliphate so it's really
interesting that's full spectrum between
a Fallujah style clearance and a hey
we're leaving and not coming back yeah
yeah that that shows you where the war
was I mean it really does now we we
start getting towards the end of year
deployment and we're starting turnover
procedures and at some point obviously
it went from hey we're gonna do a
massive kinetic sweep - all right we're
gonna continue this counterinsurgency
we're gonna start doing this in the less
kinetic way then a Fallujah style and it
starts to become time for you guys to
kind of kind of pack up head home mm-hmm
you when you guys as a unit head back
how long does that redeployment take
well the the relief in place about two
weeks so you know we call it left seat
right SIA so for the first week that the
brigade that's going to take our place
gets there we're still in the left seat
or a driver's seat and they're observing
and then for the second week they're in
a driver seat they're on the Left seeing
them we're in the right seat observing
them so in theory it's about two weeks
and that's about what it was maybe it
was ten days instead of 14 and then when
we get back we went back down to Kuwait
for a few days and then got back over to
the States there I think was Fort Dix
where we actually D mode that and that
was I think about five or six days so
there wasn't a lot of there really
wasn't that much time to decompress
before sending these National Guard
soldiers which I like
and obviously like we already talked
about had some active duty forces with
me too but for the National Guard units
that were with me to go back into their
civilian environments it wasn't a lot of
decompression time I mean you get right
down to from leaving an environment like
Ramadi I mean the a dangerous chaotic
environment like that to going back and
doing whatever their civilian job was
but that that's the other thing about
the guard that I just want I don't know
if we emphasize it enough is the the
unique thing with the National Guard
they have their military training so
they could do their military skill but
then they also bring civilian skills
with them I'll give you an example I had
some officers who worked in the police
departments here in the States and we
had them working with Iraqi police to
try to help them become better police
you know we had you know we had
everything that we had bankers we had
carpenters we had electricians and a lot
of that led to creating better a better
infrastructure at our combat outpost and
other places so our soldiers could live
a little bit more of a better life when
that when they when they weren't out on
patrol so a lot of these civilian skills
that the guard have actually pays
dividends when you go into a combat
situation a lot of people don't think
about that it it's crazy for me to think
now we we've kind of changed our
perspective now on how you decompress
people and even like in the SEAL Teams
when we came home from Ramadi we got on
a plane we flew home and we were home
yeah but we will to be quite frank what
we did was they sent us to we went to a
bar and we drank and we and they had
they had guys to shuttle us home with
our one new guy would drive our car and
the other new guy would drive wouldwould
sorry one new guy would drive us in our
car to our house another new guy would
follow him and take him back to do the
next run for the next guy not exactly
what you would call a good plan for
decompression and now they do a much
better job but I it's you know one of
the best things that you can do when you
come home as you want to spend time with
the people that you were there with you
want to tell stories you want to get it
out of your system you want to laugh you
want to cry you want to
you want to kind of dislike with like
you said decompress for the soldiers
coming home and then they're rolling
back into a civilian job and all of a
sudden they're not seeing their their
their friends every day the people that
they just served with what did it look
like from your position as the commander
as all that unfolded what were the
reports coming back where guys getting
in trouble was it useful and one thing
that I tell military guys all time
active-duty guys when they get out
whether they just get out of whether you
retire like you got to find a new
mission right so I imagine some people
hey it's time to go back to work okay go
back to work they kind of get back into
that mission but for me I always see
guys that have the most trouble when
they don't have they don't have a job to
go into they don't have anything to do
and now they kind of the devil's what is
it the the idle hands are the devil's
plaything yeah yeah you know I think in
again I had 35 States contribute
soldiers to 2nd Brigade 28th ID and so
you know the main states were Vermont
Pennsylvania and and Utah so for those
states I think things were a little bit
easier because at least you still had
soldiers from your state from your unit
even though you might be miles apart but
still relatively close in hand but for
the other soldiers that we're we might
have got you know you know 40 soldiers
from Illinois or you know another you
know another hundred and thirty soldiers
from Michigan I mean a lot harder
because people don't know what those
soldiers really went through I mean they
read about if they saw it on the news
but they weren't there and you probably
know Jocko that it's pretty hard to talk
to somebody who hasn't been there about
what we've been through I could have a
much easier time talking you about this
than I could to somebody who's never
been there and and even if I'm just
talking to an acquaintance somewhere if
they never served there I really don't
like to talk about it too much with them
now if it was somebody who was there
yeah a little bit more of a bond so it
is very difficult for National Guard
soldiers because they aren't as they're
not staying in the same you know
military post or base that a seal is or
an active-duty soldier or marine might
be so that that is a difficult part and
we just try to keep an eye on each other
and that's what we've tried to do and
when we when we came back home I will
tell you there were some suicides and
and there were some other issues that
even though the stay soldiers are still
still trying to deal with and it's it's
a never-ending fight once you come back
from a place like that what was your
situation when you got home did you stay
on active duty for a while did you go
back to work yeah I did stay on at that
point in time I wasn't with the family
business anymore at this point in time I
was already off working with a
consulting firm in the Philadelphia
region so yeah I stayed on active duty
for for a few months and then I went
back to work one thing I did have the
opportunity to do we did have 15 of our
Pennsylvania National Guardsmen get
killed in action over there and I had an
opportunity to - I just made it a point
to go see the families and I just have
to say how much respect I have for the
families and as you know whenever one of
our brothers are you know brothers get
get killed and you know thank God
although I had 200 female soldiers with
me in the brigade
none of the females were killed over
there but I always feel bad for the
family you know yeah I feel bad if I
lose a friend obviously feel terrible
about it but the thing that hits me most
emotionally is when I think about the
family but the family is going through
with that mother and father are going
through with the brothers the sisters
are going through with the wife or you
know going through the spouse is going
through and that's what gets me most
emotional when I think about that and I
wanted to go and visit those families
and they're remarkable I thought there
might be some that would be very very
angry and every one of them respected
the sacrifice that their that their
loved one had made so that just really
heartened me about the fact that it was
even though it was the
soldier that made the decision to join
the family still supported that decision
and supported the sacrifice that they
made and that really heartened me in a
way I do want to talk about so I don't
know if you know this or not but we
created a war memorial to the Fallen
them yeah I do know that I've seen it
it's pretty it's pretty special was
around December of 2005 I was talking to
my sergeant major and we decided that at
that point in time I can't remember
exactly what the number of K I was in in
December but it was at least 40 I know
that much and we just decided that we
should create some type of memorial to
these soldiers and Marines and and by
the way at the end of the day by time we
had left their liver three Navy corpsman
that had been killed in action there too
but at any rate we put out the word in
the brigade that we wanted to have a
memorial to these soldiers and one of
our Pennsylvania National Guardsmen came
forward were to design it was a female
she was an art teacher in her civilian
job and she put out this concept I
remember when she described it to myself
in the sergeant major I think in early
January I actually brought tears to my
eyes it was an obelisk and a pair of dog
tags for every soldier that was killed
but hang inside of this obelisk and it
would have cuts through it the cuts
looked like it was shrapnel cuts and and
and a machine gun fired into it too and
as the wind would blow through this o
BLISK as the dog tags would clink
together in the wind the symbolism was
to fallen warriors as they continued to
speak to us so think about that and so
we we we had our soldiers in the
maintenance units build this memorial in
Ramadi we dedicated it on Easter Sunday
April 16 2006 we dedicated we had I
think it was at that time about 72 of
our
soldiers had been killed and Marines and
others have been killed in action at
that time and we had the deputy
commander from the marine division there
for this ceremony we had and all the
battalion commanders were there and it
was just a special tribute and we took a
risk because you don't want that many
people you know congregated in one spot
at any area and there and we did have
our share of rockets and mortars falling
on the Ford Operating Base and we have
this memorial ceremony in in April and
then when we left there in June we
deconstructed it put it in a connect
ship to back home and then in October
2016 we rededicated it in at forty
Indian town gap it still stands there to
this day I think it's one of the only
war memorials that was designed and
built and dedicated in a war zone and
then deconstructed and rededicated back
here in the United States I don't know
if there's another memorial like that
when we left Ramadi there were 81 pair
of dog tags hanging in that memorial our
last soldier died after we returned he
was a sergeant a filler Killary sergeant
who had serious burns and for months was
in treatment at Brooke Army Medical
Center and succumbed to his wounds
that had received the November of 2005
he succumb to those wounds in July 2006
and he was the last set of dog tags that
we hang is that hung inside of that
memorial and again it took me years
before I could explain to you what I
just did without crying and just that
symbolism of the unites there on
Memorial Day the symbolism is the wind
blows through that Oh bless those dog
tags clink together those fallen
warriors continuing to speak to us I
think is just so powerful and that's why
I think events where we do something in
honor of a fallen warrior are so
important because I believe whenever we
speak a fallen warriors name or do
something in there
we keep their spirit on earth alive you
know I think there's something powerful
that keeping their spirit on earth alive
think about that I'm sorry to deviate
here for a minute but we do this March 4
to fall in that I think you're you're
aware of it's a 28 mile ruck march we do
it for Denis in town gap very similar to
the Bataan Memorial Death March we
usually get about a thousand people
there every year and everyone does that
ruck march in honor of a fallen warrior
and when you're out there doing a
20-month 28 mile ruck march with a 35
pound pack your feet are bleeding a
little bit you're sweating you tear up
now and then when you're thinking about
what you're doing
what better dedication to keep the
spirit of the Fallen warrior alive it's
just amazing I just think it's an
important thing to do you know Memorial
Day is an important holiday remembering
our fallen is so important we could
never forget the sacrifice they made and
we could never forget the families that
are still suffering to this day that
lost loved ones in Iraq and Afghanistan
and that memorial March is up it's open
to the public right yeah open to the
public
September 26 this year so far it has not
been canceled because of the kovat or
anything if people google March for the
Fallen to 2020 it'll come up I just
googled it today to make sure you know
what it would come up and it came up I
googled March 4 to fall in 2020 it was
the first thing to come up you'll see
it's at 14 in town Gap Pennsylvania 28
mile ruck march in honor of those fallen
warriors and and just a great tribute to
keep the spirit of these fallen warriors
alive no doubt about it
that's um and I remember seeing that
obelisk when I got there you get you
know you guys down on the ground
I think I got there right around the
time it was dedicated and I forget the
exact date I'm gonna I'm gonna actually
try and figure that out because I should
know that date but you know you were
telling me earlier and then I agreed you
know you said you asked me if I kept the
journal in Ramadi I said no and you said
you had neither and both of us wish that
we had because you know you you just the
little dates like that of they mean a
lot and
but I remember I remember seeing that
and you know of course it's very
sobering you know for when I showed up
there and look we knew what we were
getting into and so you know to see to
see that Monument to see those those dog
tags and and know what each one of those
represents was definitely a very somber
and very solemn moment and you're
absolutely correct
every time you you talk about the people
that you know the people that you lost
it it they're spirits still here yeah
you know that's one of the best things
about the job that I do you know I go
around and talk to companies and even
right here right now this is what we're
doing you know we got we got friends we
got people that sacrificed so we can sit
here today you know and then we can
never forget that yeah I can never
forget their families and you know it
should inspire our warriors to continue
to adhere to our values and continue to
drive on what whatever mission it is
because of all these soldiers from every
war that that that made the ultimate
sacrifice to build the country that we
have and I know you know obviously a lot
of social unrest and there's a lot of
things that may not be perfect about our
country but I could guarantee you this
after being over in Iraq after spending
the last three years in Europe and
traveling to about 40 different
countries over there there is no country
that is as great as our country and in
many many different ways so it's an
imperfect country but it's it's it's a
country that people from all over the
world want to gravitate to and come here
we just got to all work together to keep
this country great that's what that was
about that we all work together to to to
gain the promise that our forefathers
one of this country to be and they
probably you know hate when they wrote
that Constitution they knew it wasn't a
perfect Constitution for a lot of
reasons primarily because of slavery and
we have to just keep working at things
to make this country what it needs
be and we all need to work together then
to achieve that you ended up going to 40
different countries when I when I was
over in Europe in the last three years
yeah yeah yeah and many of them many
times over so was that did you so you
picked up so you got home from Ramadi
what was your next what happened then
yeah when I got home from Ramadi I did
get promoted to become a one-star I
worked at our joint force headquarters
at Indian town gap and then in 2011 I
was asked by our adjutant general to
come on full-time so I served full-time
for a year as as one of the deputy
Adjutant General's at our John Force
Headquarters and then I was given the
honor of commanding the 28th Infantry
Division for over three years so I did
that full-time from - from 2012 until
2016 and then in 2016 I had the honor of
getting an assignment to go to US Army
Europe in Wiesbaden Germany for three
years as one of the deputy commanding
generals there and I served over there
again for three years worked with our
NATO allies and other European partners
and I have the greatest respect for our
allies over there was in Ukraine many
times to the training center that we
have there - as a Ukrainian battalion
rotates out of the dumb boss region
where they're still fighting the Russian
LED separatists there and by the way
when I left there about 30 Ukrainian
soldiers were getting killed every month
so I mean it's still a war going on in
the dumb boss region but battalions
would rotate out at the dawn boss the
Ukrainian battalions they'd come back to
Western Ukraine to a training area that
we had there and the United States
Canada Lithuania and Poland would work
together to help this battalion train to
be a more effective fighting unit and so
was there many times but uh yeah spent a
lot of time in Poland and the three
Baltic countries down in the Balkans I
mean I was all over the place did you do
you speak any polish very very little
yeah very I could say goodnight and
hello and those type of thing the funny
thing is you know my grandmother and
father you know my grandmother died when
I was 10 so I remember my grandmother
and father speaking polish together and
the reason they didn't want to teach any
of us kids polish is so they could talk
in Polish without us knowing what they
were trying to say so they didn't try to
teach us the language one of my friends
that was in the SEAL Teams with me his
he was his dad was a was a Mexican yeah
and you know and the kid looked Mexican
and you know I said and he he had a
little bit of an accent you know a
little bit of an accent just from
growing up with his dad who spokes spoke
Spanish and and who to this guy's you
know admission he said you know my dad
didn't really speak you know didn't
really speak English very well at all
and his mom spoke Spanish too
and I said oh that's why you have a
little bit of an accent he said yeah you
know that's probably where it comes from
and I said well you know at least at
least you speak Spanish and he goes no I
don't speak Spanish
his dad refused to have him speak
Spanish
because his dad wanted him to be an
American yeah and and even though his
dad wasn't you know great with English
he wouldn't speak to him in Spanish and
I thought that's where you're gonna go
you know cuz that was kind of the old
the old attitude it was hey we're in
America now yeah so interesting story
you know I I did you know have this
little thing that you you put together
when when you were the commanding
general there the two to eight there was
a couple little things I just wanted
highlight you mean at the 28th ID not
the two to eight oh sorry yes the 28th
ID yeah when you were the division
commander right you had a sort of
guidance for your troops and there's
just a couple good leadership things in
here it says every leader is trusted and
expected to use disciplined initiative
within the commander's intent without
wasting time requesting permission
report up as the situation develops
request further guidance or support as
necessary demonstrating a high level of
initiative is worth the risk of making
honest mistakes
so great concise statement there you
know I think that came from my time in
Ramadi where I realized you know as we
were in distributed operations there I
mean most operations were conducted at
the platoon level there and you know the
situation was so dynamic that you
couldn't waste time asking your
higher-level leader we know what should
I do you know you had a you had a show
initiative and so when I came back I
knew our soldiers were gonna continue to
deploy overseas as a matter of fact we
have elements of our Aviation Brigade in
Pennsylvania getting ready to go over to
Afghanistan and I just knew this was
going to be a long war we were going to
continue to deploy troops over there and
I realized one of my jobs is the
division commander even if we didn't
deployed an entire division over there I
had units going over had to get him
ready to fight in chaotic situations and
the best way to do that was to help them
understand the need to develop
initiative and we had to do that in a
training environment so that when they
got to a combat environment they would
continue to do that this is the thing if
in a training environment you don't
allow your soldiers or in a civilian
organization you don't allow your your
people say in a steady state operation
to demonstrate initiative then when you
get as a soldier deploy overseas if
you're not used to displaying initiative
in a training environment guess why it
doesn't automatically flip a switch in
its combat now I'm going to show some
initiative that doesn't happen the same
in a civilian civilian company you're
damned if you don't allow your employees
to demonstrate an initiative steady
state then when you hit something like
the corona of ice covet 19 hey you know
they're not automatically going to
display initiative so I think it's
important to encourage that before
you're in a crisis yeah no doubt about
that I that was always my main goal well
you know it's whether that's the fourth
the fourth law of combat that I talked
about is decentralized command and and
it's the most powerful of the of the
laws of combat that I talked about not
that the other ones aren't powerful but
you can't have decentralized command you
have cover move unless you have Keefe
unless you keep things simple unless you
prioritize and execute those thing
don't really work decentralized command
cannot work without those three but once
you implement decentralized command this
is what allows a team to really do well
yes
everybody leads that's what you want so
what was your last tour in the army
my last churned army was as uh was as
one of the deputy commanding generals at
US Army Europe I served there from 2016
to 2019 I left Europe in April 2019 and
then retired in Pennsylvania in June
2019 two months after I left Europe and
then well at what point did you start
writing the book you know the funny
thing with the book is again I did this
bicycle trip with my wife and 15 month
old son in 1983 so here was 2019 just
retired from the Army sitting around a
fire pit with my younger son Timothy and
he starts asking me questions about this
bike trip I didn't talk about it all
that much for some reason and I start
telling them stories and we're laughing
and they goes dad he goes you should
write a book about it and so I get back
home I talking to my wife and she goes
you know John I think that's a good idea
because your kids and your grandkids
need to know the story and I do have two
grandchildren and I said you know what
if nothing else just for the family you
know to have this store so I I took this
journal that I kept on the bike trip
that was sitting in a shoebox literally
a shoebox for over 35 years
use that as a basis to write the book
and then because I am as passionate
about leadership as you are Jaakko I I
wanted to put a leadership component in
there because there were so many
leadership elements to that by trip and
so I wrote the book I started in the
fall of 2019 and then was able to get a
published in February of 2020 quick
turnaround
you know I that like I said there's a
ton of stuff great stuff inside this
book I want to read one more chunk of it
pretty pretty good chunk here and then
the part this is a part called
leadership and and look you've got these
leadership lessons kind of strewn
throughout and you you
put an exclamation point on them here
you you say this character competence
and resilience are essential essential
for effective leadership leaders must be
true to their values even when their
backs are against the wall leaders must
cultivate trust by trusting others first
sharing the load and following through
on promises leaders must care more about
those they lead than they care about
themselves leaders must clearly
communicate a vision or action an action
plan that is realistic and believable be
problem-solvers and have the courage to
make decisions leaders must help others
develop and become stronger and leaders
must be fit in many ways including
physical spiritually mental and
emotional fitness leaders must have the
resilience to overcome adversity
resiliency is not only about toughness
but it's also about exuding positive
energy that inspires others having a
positive attitude is essential we choose
how we feel we can choose to be happy or
sad angry or calm upbeat or down
organizations and teams take on the
attitude and person and personality of
their leaders the attitudes of those on
the team reflect the leaders attitude if
your team has a bad attitude look in the
mirror and those that's an example of
some of the you know just just powerful
leadership lessons that you have inside
this book ton of other ones in there and
you know I know we've been going for
almost three hours right now and as I
told you earlier I could sit here and
listen to your perspectives on this
stuff all day long
but I'm not gonna keep you as a prisoner
here general gronski where let's talk
about where people can find you what
you're doing right now I know you've got
your consulting company tell us a little
bit about that and where we can find you
yeah the consulting company is leader
Grove LLC website leader groves calm or
John gronski calm
both websites link to one another and
you know I'm pretty active on Instagram
on Facebook on Twitter on LinkedIn so
people could you know search for me
there and and your Twitter is JL gronski
your YouTube with John gronski your
Linkedin is John gronski your Facebook
is John gronski leads I didn't find your
Instagram you got it
John gronski leads okay yeah you're
getting on the gram yeah echo Charlie
likes to call it that's where people can
find you and you're you're available to
speak you're available to you consulting
the whole nine yards yeah yeah I'm a
professional speaker i I do leadership
consulting I have many different clients
throughout the country and yeah I'd love
to do what I'm passionate about awesome
echo yeah the other thing so so just so
I know you listen you said you listened
the podcast and I'm sure you know that
echos been sitting here for three hours
and something caught his mind two hours
and 32 minutes ago and he's been having
this question broomy you know is that
the chaco I don't want to be like the
only person in the United States who
doesn't listen to your podcast so yes I
listened to your podcast oh this is this
is actually gonna be super simple and
easy I think you mentioned something
real quick and brief the left seat right
seat like and what is that in current
when you transition yeah when when one
brigade is getting ready to leave and
another Brigade is coming in to take
over that mission
the brigade that's getting ready to
leave for the first let's say for the
first week is in the left seat which
means they're still in a driver seat
there's been doing the mission and the
incoming Brigade is observing in the
kind of in the right seat in the
passenger seat and then the following
week the brigade that is now newly
taking the mission will be in the left
seat or the driver seat in the brigade
that's about to leave is in the right
seat observing and then once that is
done the brigade that was there has gone
home and to be honest with you echo
usually most units
want that to be done as quickly as
possible to being quite honest about it
uh yeah maybe like feel like they're
holding their hand or something like
that yeah like oh we got this already
kind of thing I thought of it in terms
of like you know how like with your kids
right you want to you want to train them
to do their own stuff right and just
simplifying it like that and having that
to kind of like consider like the whole
situation or whatever um I feel like
that was kind of useful cuz I figured
that's what it meant you know less seat
drivers passenger seat you after certain
amount of time when the passengers like
yeah I think I can drive well that is
kind of a way to train somebody you know
first you do don't let them observe no
first you tell them how to do it then
you do it and have them observe and then
you have them do it and you observe yeah
you know after a while you just kind of
leave yeah and they got it yeah yeah
it's the way it works
my recommendation is just stay humble
when you're getting the turnover from
somebody yeah and listen to what they
say you they know things you don't know
and it's actually crazy to me to think
about trying to transfer knowledge like
when the guys came in to relieve task
unit bruiser inside Ramadi I was trying
to tell them you know we're all everyone
in the chain of commands just trying to
give them all this information cuz you
know you know how hard it is and you're
just just trying to give them there's no
possible way you can transfer them all
the knowledge that you have and you're
doing your best so when you come into
those situations as a leader open up
your mind open up your brain try and
absorb what people are telling you there
look they've you might have a different
vision it doesn't matter
listen to what they say have an open
mind sir got any other any any final
thoughts you know just one final thought
we you know we talked about the
experience over there and the final
thought I guess is how important
families are to everything we do we
can't do what we do without the support
of our families and I remember a senior
leader telling me number of years ago
you know one of the army values is
loyalty and he said when we talk about
the army value of loyalty and not only
means loyalty to your unit it also means
being loyal to your fan
and that really stuck with me because
you don't yeah I didn't hear too many
senior leaders talking about that up to
that point and so whenever I talked to
soldiers after that I will always remind
them you got to be loyal to your family
as well as to your unit and that's and I
think that's very important so I guess
the final point is we just got to be so
thankful for the support we have from
our families you know whatever that
family unit might look like because we
can't do what we do without the support
of others amen to that
and once again thank you so much for
coming here today thank you for teaching
all these great lessons about leadership
and life and of course and obviously
thank you for everything you did for
America for 40 years of service and
specifically thank you for what you did
for the soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines that served with you in the
battle or mati you and your troops set
conditions for victory and the men of
the two to eight will always be revered
by the seals of task unit bruiser for
guiding us into combat and standing by
our side on the battlefield and we will
never forget the sacrifice of those
fallen heroes those iron soldiers who
gave their lives for us thank you for
everything
Thank You Chuck oh it's really an honor
to be here with you and love the message
that that you get out there and echo
gets out there alongside you thanks for
thanks thanks for those important
leadership messages got you get out I
have to tell you I did read extreme
ownership and I loved every page of it
it's an excellent book and something
that anyone who's interested in becoming
a better leader can learn from thank you
sir appreciate it and with that general
john gronski has left the building
just awesome to see him again
and awesome to talk to him and awesome
to get those lessons learned mm-hmm
now they must be applied yeah that
controls any lessons that you think we
could apply any things we could do to
make ourselves better yes left seat
right see you like that one yeah very
much so and here's the thing it made
scent like I wasn't confused as to what
it was because once he once you realize
all you're talking about the driver's
seat in the passenger seat that's what
you're talking about
and because you know how like when
you're trying to train somebody up you
know we should actually talk about like
long - you know from a long time ago I'm
like okay yeah cool cool but when you
try to do that it's like what's the best
I know I got to be a good trainer and
like all this stuff that I worry about
and I'm talking about like kids I'm
talking about like various you know
things mmm but that's a good just
simplistic way of like keeping your mind
wrapped around it you know and actually
in a way meth a method right like you'll
all just do it you just watch if you
have questions ask all you can walk
myself through it while I'm doing it
teaching my daughter how to make rice or
I did and then good year though whatever
and yeah I'm just walking it through and
I actually did that the whole front seat
I'm not friends laughs see right seat
you know did it mmm I said boom this is
how many cups of water boom that
somebody cups rice he's doing and she's
just listening say do it say do it I
just walk her through it but I do it do
it again do it again not you know the
same day I'm just saying Dave day after
day and then after a while you're like
okay let's switch seats but I'm in the
Front's I'm in the passenger seat right
still offering you know tips or whatever
worked we're good to tips on making rice
yes sir without a rice maker in why
everybody hasn't racing you just put the
rice in the water you press the button
it's good you press the one the button
you press the button easy money either
way rice no rice whatever this is what
we're gonna do supplementation let me go
deep on this right now
okay so I was up on the the Joe Rogan
pod
I got a kovat 19 test yes there when I
got the test the doctor came a doctor
came to give me the test he came to test
you prick my finger we have to wait 15
minutes the antibody tests though to be
specific yes find out if I've had this
yes I developed this he knew you know
it's telling him hey look I went to
Seattle I went to New York I went to San
Francisco I went to LA I mean I was in
the hot zones I was at Ground Zero for
kovat at the end of January on planes
everywhere he and and kept traveling I
stopped traveling March 14th I think I
was traveling in airplanes all over the
place I did not have the antibodies
mm-hmm and what he said was with the
amount of the amount of travel done in
that exposure I've had I've been exposed
to it he said sometimes people's immune
systems are strong to the point where it
doesn't even register this little kovat
nineteen rolls in and it just gets
crushed yeah so immune system to things
look vitamin d3 which I take chakra fuel
d3 I take it I take it every day as a
matter of fact I take more than the
recommended dose for whatever reason I
take one of the morning I take one at
night I take cold war which has all
those immune supplementation's and for
some reason look I'm healthy yes I eat
good yes why not just kick it up so who
knows who knows I'm just saying maybe
not a coincidence like you heard what a
Rhonda doctor round of Patrick said
right on Joe's podcast talking about
vitamin D and how helpful it is how it
helps with that I take that religiously
I take the Cold War religiously and all
of a sudden I'm in all these horrible
places and I'm just kovat free no factor
look can I make a claim that these
supplements
we'll stop covert night no I can't make
that claim but I can tell you a little
story
so anyways look those are the facts a
lot of exposure no kovat 19 no and by
the way we're doing jiu-jitsu at maybe
there's multi I mean it's crazy
what I expose my immune system to no
factor what covin what yeah so there are
those out that is crazy because even
when you think about your like your it's
not like you're let's say a singer you
know or whatever you're putting on
concert singing into the microphone sign
a few autographs even though I'm not
autograph I didn't you really I'm
shaking a thousand rubles a bunch of bro
hug and pull it's crazy
yeah yeah shaking everyone so you can
advertise up everyone having
conversations with them basically she's
in conversations where they're like
telling me a secret about something yeah
they're in my face when they started the
whole social distancing that became an
actual like word or whatever the number
one thing handshakes number one thing oh
yeah and you're doing that to everybody
different lines of people from all over
the country by the way when I went to
those cities there was you know but
whatever percentage of the audience they
didn't they weren't from DC they weren't
from New York they drove there from
wherever else so you got this massive
cesspool of bacteria and I'm just all up
in it but I got that D mmm yeah sure
amen so your body was just like hey we
don't we don't need antibodies for their
light of what and that way it's kind of
like you know when you're gonna um like
I don't maybe the police force or
something like that where it's like hey
we have a situation then the police
force like mounts up and they're like
okay what's the situation then they say
the situation they're like oh no we
don't need all these guys it was
actually frozen Fred from the front desk
or whatever like those got that okay and
handle business you know whatever so
that's what happened yeah interesting
oh yeah the Cold War is there to also
discipline mm-hmm and just blink oh this
helps your brain you know so if you want
to figure out how you did or did not get
goof in 99 you figure it out better I
guess this
it might need some protein get some milk
your kids might need protein get some or
your kid milk you might need some ready
to drink cans which I've been drinking
today
yeah plus you can get this stuff at
origin main comm you can also get it at
the vitamin shop right yeah also at
origin main comm get some cool jiu-jitsu
stuff these brass rash guards other
stuff too
yeah on there also jeans american-made
denim american-made denim not the kind
you go down to wherever and get them
sewn and bleached and do they bleach
jeans yeah sometimes sometimes or acid
washed remember acid wash yes I do yeah
it's old or you know distressed or
whatever cuz you know they distress yes
in the our stuff look like someone's
lived in them yeah like don't like
someone did something cool and by the
way it's so obvious when you see those
three what are they what do they call
that
oh no no no there's a word distressed
yeah like pre-distressed disaster a
distress factory district school yeah
and then ship them over and then you
know then hey you know here's some jeans
which you know I don't know it's not
that is what I'm saying you know all
made in America the actual Nano made in
America also we got boots works of art
yeah that were according to yeah order
those get what you need man we're there
and we're making everything that we're
talking about in America that's what
we're doing that's how we're doing it
also chocolates store we have a store
online store chocolate store calm is
where you can get your discipline equals
freedom hoodies t-shirts rash guards
hats women's stuff on there as well tank
tops and shirts whatnot that's if you
want to represent while you're on the
path true very very track could not have
said it better
yes also also on Jocko store we have an
email list I'm not why I'm not gonna be
use anyone's email ever ever in my whole
life ever straight up I'm making that
Automation right now okay but if you'd
sign if you want to sign up for our
email list when I say our email list
it's like mining Jacko's that those are
the only people are gonna email you
straight up so if you want to sign up
for this it's mainly gonna be store
stuff like and not like everyday
emailing you
oh we changed the color of our website
Brad I don't I don't email that kind of
stuff because I don't think anyone cares
about that stuff only if there's like a
new design or yeah that's pretty much so
maybe like once them I don't know it's
not very often but I'm gonna put
extensive effort into making it stuff
that I really believe that it is worth
sending out see I'm saying worth
receiving worth opening up as an email
you're making me want to sign up for
your email list just so I can make just
so I can police you to make sure you're
not sending out stuff that you shouldn't
he said I should be blow I'm saying if I
was a listener cuz I am on the email
list but if I was just a listener out
there in the world I might go
echoes making a claim I'm gonna check it
good I think that that's a good thing to
do it I go sends a lame email let me
know respond to it and just say hey this
was a lame email so maybe check next
time you send maybe like read you know
confirm it or something you know
give it a once-over I don't know but
nonetheless for real I respect I respect
the inbox check also we got a podcast
right now that you're listening to if
you want to you can subscribe to it if
you want to you can leave a review we
also have some other podcasts we got the
thread that I'm still working on the
name change every good name I think of
as kind of taken so I'm bummed out we
have the grounded podcast was about
jujitsu and life we got the warrior kid
podcast for your warrior kids we also
have warrior kids soap from Irish Oaks
ranch calm it's also available we're on
Dunkel stored almond chocolate store
calm young Aden making soap building a
business who here was building a
business when they were 12 years old now
he's older now but he started that
business we was 12 credit don't forget
to we have a youtube channel and at some
point echo charles is going to start
putting easter eggs
of special-effects into the YouTube
version of this podcast maybe a little
sound effect maybe an explosion so good
opportunities today
well technically those aren't Easter
eggs okay what are they okay
well he's not just sound effects visual
effects maybe some smoke maybe some fire
maybe some explosions it's funny that
you get you make a four-minute video and
you show 97 explosions but you do a
three-hour video and there's nothing in
it what do you think people think of
that I think explosions have their place
in the world you know and I do too well
we'll have varying levels of agreement
on that don't you think people would
okay do you think do you think watching
a three-hour youtube video is boring
it's you and me talking do you think
that might be boring to someone visually
three hours well visually boring and
boring or two different things visually
boring yes or no I can see yes or no if
if put it this way well it's not a yes
or no question right it is yes is it
boring to watch three hours of a video
of two humans in a black room talking to
each other yes or no it's not a no
question it depends who the humans okay
politician no we gotta get you got a you
gotta understand okay well let's say it
was let's say with some subject like
someone trying to explain how to cook
rice do you think that might get boring
now if the rice cooker was blowing down
okay anyway yes subscribe to the YouTube
channel
yeah subscribe to the YouTube channel if
you want to see that and Ecko does make
other enhance videos and if you want to
see stuff blow up you can see it there
mmm if you want to see if I want to be
if you want to be bored then you can
watch the for our podcast if it's not
boring how about that okay
visually boring anyway psychological
warfare psychological or fur if you
having a moment of weakness which we all
do had one the other day
or through it by the way what was it
wait
oh you didn't want to I didn't feel like
it and freaking didn't feel it but this
was like next level didn't you like it
the kind of work you know the kind where
you don't feel like it's so hardcore
where you let man miss something might
be like wrong with me you know I wasn't
feeling physically weak necessarily but
I was just like maybe like something's
going on
maybe it's like actual like burnout you
know you know that deal the only the
when I do 20 reps squats do it heavy
sure sometimes while I'm doing them I'm
thinking to myself I don't care I don't
care if I'm strong I don't care if I
don't care if I'm in shape whatever I'm
doing right now I just I would rather be
watching TV I just want to stop this and
yeah that's right that's a bad thing
yeah a child for that you know so the
point is then I get mad about that and
then I do bro I you think because you
didn't do rugged we're talking about
that how you like get mad at your dad at
that and here's the thing it's easy to
be like oh that's a good thing I'm gonna
try that but if you don't genuinely get
mad at yourself it totally doesn't work
you can kinda get mad at yourself or
maybe feel guilty later but that's
different that's not even the same thing
if you're for real mad at yourself that
you literally deserve punishment
immediately like right now though your
ways load up the bar yeah exactly a bar
and get under there and get some man if
you can get there if you can pull it off
mentally very very helpful by the way
but let's say you can't let's say you
can't guess what psychological warfare
boom listen to Joc well he'll tell you
pragmatically give you practical ways to
think and be like oh yeah wait why
should I know I shouldn't skip this
where I should actually do this workout
get yourself through that moment of
weakness you know also if you want to
get a visual little reminder of what you
should be doing then check out flipside
canvas dot-com my brother Dakota Meyer
making those making things you can hang
on your wall that will snap your brain
into place a little bit also we got some
books obviously the book that we talked
about today the ride of our lives by
John Garang ski we got the code the
evaluation the protocols
check that one out we got leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual we
got--we the warrior kid one two and
three we got Mikey in the Dragons
apparently which is the best little kids
book that's ever been written a lot of
people are saying yeah discipline Eagles
freedom field manual imagine that a
Field Manual on discipline and then
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership which I wrote with my brother
lave babban also have a seal on front
which is my leadership consultancy where
we solve problems through leadership go
to a salon front comm if you got any
issues get any problems in your company
their leadership problems 100% think
about what I just said
100% you do not have any problems that
aren't leadership problems if you don't
believe me go to a salon front comm will
come and show you what's up
yep online this is our online leadership
training it's not just training it's us
it's me you want to talk to me go to EF
online.com and come to one of the
multiple per week live interactive
webinars that I'm doing right now with
the rest of the echelon front team go to
EF online.com all kinds of good stuff on
there unbelievable community brigade of
people and they're getting after it
also the muster live event we're doing
the next one in Phoenix Arizona
September 16th and 17th Texas Dallas
Texas December 3rd and 4th go to extreme
ownership comm for details and look we
are might have to adapt when it comes to
social distancing and whatever else we
got to do to pull these things off so
the amount of seats that we have
available might be smaller than what
would normally be available so if you
want to come to the muster then get
signed up now because we've sold out
everything even with all the capacity
being used go to extreme ownership calm
to do that we have EF overwatch if you
or your company you need experienced
leaders in your company that understand
the principles we talked about go to EF
overwatch comm to find the people you're
looking
for and don't forget about America's
mighty warriors dot-org
momily mark Lee's mom she's out there
she is on a mission to help service
members active duty retired folks folks
that just got out help them help their
families help gold star families around
the world if you want to participate in
that if you want to donate if you want
to get involved go to America's mighty
warriors dot org and if you haven't had
enough of my tedious or talking or you
need more of echos ridiculous rants then
you can find us on the interwebs on
Twitter Instagram and on Facebook echo
is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing Ken once again thanks to general
gronski for coming on and thanks to
everyone in the military for your
service especially those yes especially
those those iron soldiers of the 2nd
Brigade 28th Infantry Division for your
service and your sacrifice in the Battle
of Mahdi we'll never forget you guys and
we'll never forget your fallen brothers
and to the police and the law
enforcement out there and I'll throw a
special little shout-out to Timothy
gronski Pennsylvania State Police
trooper general groans his son to all of
you out there and then also firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol Secret Service
you're doing all that hard work out
there getting very little support we'll
just remember that there are a lot of
people that know what you do know the
risks that you take and know how many
people you help and everyone else out
there we do not know everything we do
not win every time we all make mistakes
learn from
learn from them and get better then get
back on the path and of course get after
it until next time
this is echo and Jocko out